Ich selber war ein Weizenkorn, Mit vielen, die mir anverwandt, Lag ich im lauen Ackerland. Bedrückt von einem Erdenkloss Macht ich mich mutig strebend los. Gleich kam ein alter Haas gehupft Und hat mich an der Nase gezupft, Und als es Winter ward, Verfrohr, was peinlich ist mein linkes Ohr, Und als ich reif mit meiner Sippe, Oh weh, da hat mit seiner Hippe Der Hans uns rundweg abgesäbelt Und zum Ersticken festgeknibelt Und auf die Tenne fortgeschafft, Wo ihrer Vier mit voller Kraft Im regelrechten Pflegel takte, Uns klopften, dass die Scharte knackte. Ein Esel trug uns in die Mühle, Ich sage dir, das sind Gefühle, Wenn man, zerrieben und gedrillt, Zum allerfeinsten Staubgebild, Sich kaum besinnt und fast vergisst, Ob Sonntag oder Montag ist. Und schließlich stob der Bäckermeister Nachdem wir erst als zäher Kleister In seinem droge Bass gehudelt, Vermengt, geknebelt und vernudelt Uns in des Ofens höchste Glut. Jetzt sind wir Brot. Ist das nicht gut?
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und nach einer etwas längeren Pause begrüße ich wieder alle hier zu einem neuen Marsch durch ein Thema. Ich suche mir die Themen ja immer ganz speziell aus und es hat auch immer viel mit Eigeninteresse zu tun. Wenn irgendwie Dinge zusammenkommen, wo ich eigentlich nichts von weiß, aber was mich einfach materisch interessiert, dann ist das immer das richtige Thema. Ihr werdet es schon beim Runterladen gelesen haben. Heute geht es ums Brot. Lebensmittel haben ja irgendwie einen ziemlichen Erfolg gehabt in den letzten Jahren. Bier kam gut an und auch die Kaffeefolge scheint eine Menge Freunde gefunden zu haben. Deswegen dachte ich mir, Brot passt super. Insofern begrüße ich erst mal den Lutz. Hallo, Lutz Geißler. Willkommen bei CRE. Du bist dann irgendwie so ein bisschen meine erste Wahl gewesen. Insofern freue ich mich sehr, dass das geklappt hat. Ja, Lutz, erzähl doch mal vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen was zu dir. Ich habe gerade erfahren, du bist eigentlich eigentlich bist du Wissenschaftler.
Genau, Geowissenschaftler, Geologe. Geologe.
Das ist ein bisschen naheliegend. Du kommst ja aus dem Erzgebirge oder weiss ich nicht.
Ich komme aus dem Erzgebirge, aus Freiberg. Das ist die Stadt mit der ältesten geowissenschaftlichen Universität der Welt. Also wenn man da geboren ist, möchte man auch geowissenschaftliches studieren.
In der Tat ein weltweiten Ruf. Das hat mich auch sehr überrascht, als ich das mal so mitbekommen habe. Wenn es um Bergbau geht, dann ist Freiberg echt in aller Munde.
Und entsprechend bin ich auch Lagerstädtengeologe geworden, also Bergbauaffin.
Ja.
Und warum? Es liegt ein bisschen in der Familie. Meine beiden Eltern sind Geologen. Und ich wollte es eigentlich nie werden, bin es dann doch geworden. Weil das halt einfach Theorie und Praxis zusammen ist. Physik hätte ich studieren können, Chemie hätte ich studieren können, Mathematik vielleicht auch. Aber das sind alles sehr theoretische Sachen. Da stehst du im Labor und kommst nicht raus. Und die Geologie verbindet alle Naturwissenschaften miteinander und du siehst was von der Welt. Und letzten Endes war das der ausschlaggebende Punkt.
Geologie verbindet alle Naturwissenschaften miteinander. Mehr als andere Sachen. Also könnte man ja von Mathematik auch behaupten. Aber das meinst du jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht.
Nicht wirklich. Die Geologie, da hast du Physik, Chemie, Biologie hast du dabei, Mathematik sowieso. Du hast auch Dinge, die man praktisch tun kann. Also mit dem Hammer arbeiten, Handwerk ist da dabei, Feldarbeit, Zeitgeschichte. Du bist ständig draußen, Geschichte sowieso. Viel länger, als der normale Historiker das in seinem Kopf hat. Und am Ende geht es auch um Zeiträume, die sich kein normaler Mensch vorstellen kann. Und auch das ist spannend an der ganzen Geschichte.
Und dann hast du in Freiberg das studiert.
Genau, ich habe in Freiberg Geologie-Paleontologie studiert. Das ist alles, was mit Fossilien zu tun hat.
Also eigentlich wolltest du Dinosaurier auskramen.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das ist ein Thema, was mich überhaupt nicht interessiert. Weder Dinos noch irgendwelche anderen Fossilien. Es gab halt nur damals diesen Studiengang in Kombination mit Paleontologie. Und ich habe mich dann aber relativ schnell auf die Lagerstättengeologie spezialisiert. Also alles, was mit Rohstoffen zu tun hat, die mehr oder weniger unter unseren Füßen liegen. Und bin dann über die Diplomarbeit in Nordkalifornien gelandet, im Goldbergbau und dann letzten Endes wieder im Erzgebirge im Marmowergbau.
Ist das dieses Glondeig, von dem man immer so viel hört?
So ungefähr. Das war eine alte Grube, die schon zu Goldgräber-Zeiten in Angriff genommen wurde, aber über Tage in den Fluss laufen mit Seifengold. Später hat man sich dann an den Quarzadern, wo das Gold beheimatet ist, in die Tiefe gearbeitet und hat dann um 2008 herum, da gab es trotzdem so einen Gold-Boom wieder, der Goldpreis war extrem hoch, hat man versucht, diese alten Gruben wieder zu öffnen und neu aufzuwertigen mit modernen Werkbaumethoden. Da war quasi meine Aufgabe zu schauen, wie viele Vorräte sind noch da, wie ist die Lagerstättenstruktur, wie ist die Lagerstätte entstanden, wo gibt es perspektivisch weitere Goldgänge, Quarzgänge mit Gold. Und am Ende ist da eine 500 Seiten dicke Diplomarbeit rausgeworden, die mich anderthalb Jahre lang beschäftigt hat. Und das war dann auch der Ausgangspunkt zu sagen, jetzt brauchst du mal irgendwas, was dich nicht am Rechner festhält und im Labor, sondern was was Praktisches ist. Nach der ganzen Feldarbeit war ich dann ein Jahr lang nur im Labor und am Rechner, um die ganzen Daten auszuwerten. Und in dem Zeitraum habe ich angefangen, Brot zu packen.
Auch das erste Mal?
Das allererste Mal, genau.
Und warum?
Der eine Grund war, dass ich tatsächlich was Praktisches brauchte und Ergebnisse sehen wollte am Ende des Tages. Der zweite Grund war, dass ich was brauchte, was nicht verstaubt. Also ich bin kein Freund von Dingen, die ständig irgendwo rumliegen. Sondern muss dann was Praktisches sein. Und Brot ist sehr praktisch. Selbst wenn es gelungen ist oder nicht gelungen ist, ist es am Ende weg. Und man kann noch mal von vorn anfangen. Und der dritte Grund war, wie ich dann tatsächlich aus Brotbacken gekommen bin, eine Einladung in der Verwandtschaft zum Frühstück. Und da gab es selbst gebackene Brötchen. Auch der erste Versuch. Aus heutiger Sicht waren die sicherlich nicht so, wie ich mir ein gutes Brötchen vorstelle. Aber es war der Ausgangspunkt zu sagen, jetzt probierst du das auch mal.
Also mit Bäckerlehre oder sowas hast du nie geliebeugelt. Also das Thema war auch noch nie da.
Nee, das war nie da. Ich hab als Student mein Supermarktbrot gegessen, das in Scheiben geschnitten. War ab und zu auch mal beim Bäcker.
Was ja vielleicht gab, wenn du ein schwarzes Schaf in der Familie, der nicht Geologe geworden ist.
Also es soll wohl, weiß nicht, mein Ur-Ur-Großvater, noch eine Stufe später, früher, soll wohl Bäcker gewesen sein, aber das zählt nicht wirklich.
Okay, also es ist eigentlich wirklich nur so ein Hobbyding, aber du bist ja dann total drauf abgefahren. Also du betreibst ja das Blog Plötz-Brot. Das Plötz-Block, genau. Warum heißt das so?
Das hat wieder mit meiner Bergbau-Geschichte zu tun. Es gab auch in Freiberg, war das in Freiberg, einen Alfred, hieß er Alfred, das verwechsel ich immer, auf jeden Fall. Ich sag Schmiedhuber mit Nachnamen. Und der war Steiger, also ein Bergmann letzten Endes, in Freiberg und ist dann in die Welt rausgezogen und hat Bergwerke geleitet und Erfahrungen gesammelt. Als er dann wieder kam als Senior, hat er all diese Erfahrungen in ein Buch gepackt mit einem Protagonisten, der hieß Lutz. Eine erfundene Figur. Im Prinzip ist er das gewesen. Er hat seine Erfahrungen in Reimform gefasst, ich sag mal, der Faust des Bergbaus, mit viel Humor dazwischen. Und dieses Buch ist zumindest zu Vorwendezeiten, zu Weihnachtsvorlesungen etc. von den Professoren rezitiert wurden. Und das stand dann bei mir auch schon seit Kindesbeinen an in dem Regal, im Bücherregal. Und als ich dann 2011 war, das glaube ich, meinen Mischblock, also meinen Privatblock, aufgetrennt habe, weil die Brotfraktion immer stärker wurde und einen eigenen Namen für die Brotgeschichte brauchte, hab ich mich umgedreht zum Bücherregal, hab die Buchtitel abgescannt und da fiel mir dieses, diese Plötziade, so heißt das Buch, ins Auge.
Plötziade.
Plötziade, genau. Kann man antikvarisch, wäre relativ viel Geld erwerben. Und so entstand der Name. Also es hatte keinen Hintergrund in Sachen Brot, sondern es war einfach nur, sah gut aus, klang gut und nehm ich.
Ein Reimbuch heißt es hier.
Genau.
Untertitel Weite Fahrten und Lebensereignisse des Herrn Plötz. So sie sich des Bergwerks befließen. Von Amerika bis nach China hinein. Manch löbliches Bergwerk bracht auf die beiden.
So geht das weiter.
Also du hast in diesem Namen dann sozusagen einfach geschnappt.
Genau.
Obwohl es mit Brot eigentlich nichts zu tun hat.
Überhaupt nicht, aber mit Bergbauerngeologie. Und heute bin ich darüber ganz froh, weil es dann quasi meine beiden Professionen miteinander verbindet. Also mein Firmenname, in der mittlerweile selbstständig ist, Plötz Brot, habe ich also die Brotfraktion im Namen und auch meine Geologie.
Genau. Also du bist so ein bisschen auf den Brotfilm hängen geblieben, sage ich mal. Haben dir die ersten Brötchen kamen dann wohl zu gut an, oder?
Wahrscheinlich zu schlecht bei mir selbst.
Ja, weil ich meine, wenn man kein positives Feedback gibt, dann lässt man sowas ja auch schnell mal wieder sein, oder?
Nicht unbedingt. Ich habe ja für mich selbst gebacken. Es ging ja gar nicht darum, dass es wirklich schmeckt und dass es gut aussieht. Es ging einfach nur darum, dass ich was anderes mache, als am Rechner sitzen oder im Labor am Mikroskop haken.
Na gut, aber irgendwann will man ja dann auch mit den Ergebnissen dann auch vorankommen, oder?
Genau, das war der Grund, warum ich weitergemacht habe. Ich habe relativ schnell die ersten Ergebnisse in den Blog gestellt, den es damals schon gab, aber mit tausend anderen Themen. Und nur für mich, dass ich eine Art Rezeptverwaltung habe. Und da gab es dann irgendwann die ersten Rückmeldungen per Zufall, also irgendeine Suchmaschine hat das wahrscheinlich gefunden. Dann kamen die ersten Leute darauf. Am Anfang habe ich auch nur Rezepte verlinkt, also die Quellen quasi verlinkt und mein Ergebnis als Foto da reingestellt. Und mit den ersten Nachfragen habe ich dann natürlich auch die ersten Antworten geliefert und bin selber ins Club hingekommen, was machst du hier, was machst du falsch. Und war dann auf der Suche nach einem Buch, was das Ganze irgendwie erklären kann, verständlich erklären kann und habe keins gefunden.
Du hast kein Brotbuch gefunden?
In deutscher Sprache zumindest nicht. Dann bin ich in den amerikanischen Raum gewandert.
Moment, es ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt keine Bücher übers Brot backen gibt.
Es gibt massenweise Bücher übers Brot backen, aber dann entsteht kein Brot, wie ich mir ein Brot vorstelle. Dann entsteht eher sowas wie Kuchen in Brotform, also mit viel, extrem viel Hefe gebacken. Es ist eine relativ krümelige Struktur, sehr feste Teige, was dann zu trockenen Broten führt. Also all das habe ich auch ohne Buch hinbekommen.
Okay, da warst du schon.
Da war ich schon, genau. Ich wollte tatsächlich mal ein Brötchen oder ein Brot backen, wie man es sich halt vorstellt, wie man es auch von einem relativ guten Bäcker kaufen kann. Und da bin ich im amerikanischen Büchermarkt fündig geworden mit ein, zwei Büchern, was man nicht glauben mag. Also ich war ja auch eine Zeit lang in den USA und hab mich von Toastbrot ernährt. Und damit ich überhaupt was zu beissen hatte, hab ich es relativ stark getoastet.
Das ist immer ganz verloren, wenn man aus Deutschland kommt, so im Ausland mit Brot.
Genau, genau. Und es gibt auch tatsächlich eine Handvoll guter Bäcker, vor allem an den Küsten in den USA. Und die haben alle ein Buch geschrieben.
An beiden Küsten?
An beiden Küsten. Vor allem an der Westküste. Aber ein paar gibt es auch an der Ostküste. Und die haben alle ein Buch geschrieben. Und von einem oder von zweien habe ich mir das Buch geleistet. Eins ist schon eher für Hobbybäcker geschrieben und das andere war ein reines Fachbuch. Und an diesen beiden Büchern habe ich mich lang gehangelt am Anfang. Und so auch die ersten relativ guten Brote gebacken. Das waren dann Brote im französischen Stil, also mit Weizenmehl hauptsächlich gebacken. Aber es war ein Anfang. Und so ging es dann weiter. Dann habe ich, ich glaube, im 2-Jahres-Abstand jeweils, also 2-mal insgesamt, so eine Art Bäcker-Walz gemacht. Also bin eine Woche lang durch Deutschland gewandert, das erste Mal, und das zweite Mal tatsächlich dann gefahren. Und habe Bäcker besucht und mitgebacken.
Bist du einfach so aufgetaucht und hast gesagt, hallo?
Nee, ich habe mich schon vorher angemeldet.
Aber auch so, mir nichts, dir nichts. Einfach so, ich würde einfach gerne mal rumkommen. Das hören die wahrscheinlich auch nicht alle Tage, oder?
Nee, das waren schon Bäcker, die entweder selbst im Netz aktiv waren. Bäcker Subke zum Beispiel war so einer, das ist ein Thüringer Bäcker. Der hat auch einen eigenen Blog gehabt. Mittlerweile, den hatte er zwar immer noch, aber der ist inaktiv, relativ inaktiv. Bei ihm war ich, dann war ich bei verschiedenen Hobbybäckern, die auch schon im Netz sich verewigt hatten mit Broten. Und habe noch ein paar Bäcker angeschrieben, die mir so irgendwo untergekommen waren oder die mich dann unter Umständen schon kannten über den Blog.
Wie lange hast du da Zeit verbracht?
Immer eine Nacht. Also eine Nacht, dann bin ich weitergezogen zu Fuß, die erste Etappe. Und war dann eine Woche unterwegs. Hab dann auf den Zeltplätzen, wo ich übernachtet hab, jeden Abend quasi die Erlebnisse, die ich hatte, vom Tag in ein Brotrezept gepackt und das dann zu Hause gebacken, dann in den Blog gestellt.
Also die Erlebnisse im Sinne von hast du dir dann da halt abgeguckt, wie die ihre Teige machen?
Ja, entweder waren es handwerkliche Dinge oder bestimmte Brotformen. Aber im Wesentlichen ging es darum, was habe ich gesehen, auch bei der Wanderung zwischen den Etappen. Zum Beispiel gab es, was war das, bin ich an irgendeinem Fluss, glaube ich, vorbeigekommen oder irgendso was war da. Und dann habe ich, das habe ich da reingemacht, ich glaube, ich habe Zwiebellauch oder so in das Brot reingelegt. Und dann beim Anschnitt hast du dann grüne Ringe drin gehabt und solche Geschichten. Also ich habe versucht, das ist dann eher was psychologisches, versucht, die Eindrücke irgendwie in ein Rezept zu gießen, die ich während der Wanderung hatte. Da spielten schon die Erfahrungen in der Bäckernacht eine Rolle, aber auch die generellen Eindrücke von der Natur, von den Begegnungen, die man hatte. Das war so der Anfang, wo ich tatsächlich Rezepte entwickelt habe. Und das war auch eine wichtige Phase, die mich jetzt zu dem Punkt geführt hat, wo ich bin. Ich bin ja mittlerweile sehr stark weggekommen, einfach nachzubacken und entwickle Rezepturen im Kopf. Also wenn ich ein bestimmtes Brot backen will, dann habe ich das Brot vorher schon einmal im Kopf gebacken und schreibe nur noch auf, wie sich die Rezeptur zusammensetzt.
Ohne überhaupt erstmal irgendwas zusammengerührt zu haben?
Genau. Und das hat den Anfang in dieser ersten Bäckerwalz gehabt.
Bäckerwalz. Was waren das so für Leute? Ich meine, Bäcker, die sich im Netz tummeln, gibt es sicherlich welche, klar, aber es sind nicht unbedingt zwei Tätigkeiten, die jetzt so Hand in Hand gehen, zumindest in der Wartungshaltung.
Das sind schon sehr offene alternative Bäcker gewesen. Also kein Bäcker, der nicht wirklich nachdenkt über das, was er da tut. Also Bäcker Subke zum Beispiel hat sehr aus DDR-Zeiten gezehrt, was die Rezepturen angeht, also ohne Backmittel zu backen, ohne andersrum eher mit Zeit zu backen, also nicht schnell schnell, sondern den Teig in Zeit zu lassen und das war schon auch ein Einfluss auf mich, zu überlegen, warum macht er denn das? Warum backt er mit Zeit und ohne Zusatzstoffe? Oder überhaupt erst mal zu überlegen, wenn er das so tut, was machen denn alle anderen Bäcker? Warum tun sie das? Und so hat sich dieses ganze Gedankenkonstrukt über die Jahre entwickelt, sodass ich jetzt mittlerweile eine sehr, sehr restriktive Backphilosophie habe, die meistens weitergeht als das, was selbst ein sehr guter Bäcker in seiner Backstoffe Ja, ich hab sie schon mal gefabriziert.
Du bist ein Hardcore-Brotbäcker geworden.
Das könnte man so sagen, ja.
Herzkonservativ. Zumindest was die Beteiligung industrieller Produkte betrifft, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Aber nicht jetzt konservativ im Sinne von, dass du immer dasselbe backst, sondern du möchtest halt schon so ein bisschen Varietät haben auf der einen Seite.
Ich backe nix doppelt. Wenn es einmal gelungen ist, wird es zu den Akten gelegt und dann kommt die nächste Idee.
Gehen wir nochmal an den Anfang. Also bevor wir uns hier konkret mal mit Broten und Mischungen und so weiter beschäftigen. Ich hatte ja vorhin schon erwähnt diese Folge, die ich mit Andreas zusammengemacht habe über Bier. Da gab es dann ganz am Anfang die Feststellung, wo kommt denn das Bier her? Und dann meinte er so, naja, vom Brot backen. Also wenn die Suppe zu lange steht, dann fängt es halt auf einmal an zu gären. Das war dann wieder so ein Aha-Moment. So ein Ding, über den man nicht wirklich nachdenkt, bis man sie dann irgendwie mal hört. Und dann sind sie irgendwie so selbstverständlich. Mit anderen Worten, Brot und Bier geht wunderbar zusammen, weil es hat letzten Endes denselben Ursprung, da nämlich, wo man Getreide und Wasser zusammenschmeißt. Aber wann ging es denn überhaupt los mit dem Brot? Also was müssen die Menschen ja auch erstmal irgendwie drauf gekommen sein? Wechseln die am Baum?
Ja, das ist die Frage, was man als Brot definiert. Mir ist eine Zahl im Kopf, dass man ungefähr vor 15.000 Jahren angefangen hat, Getreide zu nutzen. In dem Sinne, wie man es heute auch versteht. Das heißt, man hat sich Wildgräser gesammelt und die kleinen Körnerchen zu einer Art Brei verarbeitet und hat dann natürlich versucht, die Wildgräser zu selektieren. Das ist eine Art Züchtung letzten Endes. Die hatten eine gute Eigenschaft, weiterzuziehen und zu verbessern. Irgendwie ist daraus das Getreide entstanden, wie wir es heute kennen, also Weizen, Rocken und Dinkel usw.
Weil das alles so Pflanzen sind, die es so in der Form, wie wir sie heute kennen, so vielleicht noch gar nicht gab.
Oder? Ja, definitiv. Es gab wirklich Wildgräser. Wenn du heute über die Wiese läufst, dann sehen die Gräser, wenn sie geblüht haben, auch ungefähr so aus wie heute die Getreide nur, sind die kleinen Körner entsprechend fast gar nicht zu sehen. Man sieht ihnen nicht an, dass da Körner dran sind, weil die so klein sind. Und über die Jahrtausende hat der Mensch über Überzüchtung diese kleinen Körner größer gemacht, in Anführungszeichen, um einen höheren Ertrag zu haben und das Ganze besser nutzen zu können. Und das erste Brot im eigentlichen Sinne ist letzten Endes ein Fladenbrot gewesen, ohne Triebmittel, also ohne Lockerung. Man hat einfach den Brei, also Mehl und Wasser, zusammengerührt, flach irgendwo aufgestrichen und in der Sonne trocknen lassen. Dann so eine Art Knäckebrot letzten Endes gehabt.
Was heißt eigentlich, Kulturleistung war am Anfang erst mal, überhaupt zu herauszufinden, dass diese kleinen Dinger in diesen Gräsern Nahrung sein können. Das ist ja dann auch nicht unbedingt selbstverständlich, weil wenn man heute über eine Blumenwiese läuft, würde man ja auch nicht gleich anfangen, an den Halben zu lecken. Also, das ist wahrscheinlich schwer zu erklären aus heutiger Perspektive, wie man drauf gekommen ist. Aber das ist im Prinzip die Story. Also, irgendwie ist man auf diese Körner gekommen.
Na gut, die Meidetiere essen das Zeug. Warum soll es dann der Mensch nicht auch mal probieren?
Gut, aber die holen sich ja auch nicht die Körner raus. Die fressen ja dann immer gleich alles. Na gut, das lässt sich heute natürlich nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Genau, und das war ja dann im Prinzip auch so der Beginn der Menschheit, wie wir sie heute kennen, mit Sesshaftigkeit, mit Dörfern und mit Agrarstrukturen. Und da stand dann im Prinzip schon etwas Brotartiges ganz am Anfang, also dieser Flagen.
Wenn wir den Brei schon als Brot verstehen, dann schon. Brei gibt es auch heute noch in den verschiedenen Kulturen als Grundnahrungsmittel.
Also, dass man einfach nur Wasser mit Getreide gemischt hat und dann isst man einfach den Brei. Schmeckt ja auch.
Ja, kann man sich streiten, aber es ist zumindest ersättigt.
Also, genau. Na gut, die Geschmäcker sind ja verschieden. Ich glaube, damals war alles das Wohlschmecken, was einen hat überleben lassen.
Genau, und um das Ganze haltbar zu machen, hat man es einfach getrocknet und hat dann tatsächlich eine Art Knäckebrot gehabt. Und die Geschichte, die uns dann zum ersten gelockerten Brot führt, und das ist dann ein Sauerteigbrot, gibt es jetzt in zwei verschiedenen Varianten. Die klassische Variante wäre, es hat jemand vergessen, den Brei zu verarbeiten, zu fladen und zu trocknen, hat ihn stehen lassen. Dann fängt das ganze System irgendwann an zu gären, das Stichwort Bier. Es entsteht ein Sauerteig. Und um das Ganze dann nicht zu vernichten, wegzuwerfen, hat man es wahrscheinlich gebacken. Das ist die eine, also Zufall, ist Geschichte. Die andere Geschichte wäre, dass die Menschen früher auch nicht ganz so dumm waren und gezielt probiert haben, dieses Gebräu in irgendeiner Richtung mikrobiell zu verändern und daraus dann letztendlich ein Brot zu backen.
Warum nennt man das Sauerteig?
In diesem Mischmasch aus Mehl und Wasser stecken verschiedene Mikroorganismen. Das eine sind die Hefepilze, das andere sind Milchsäurebakterien. Und die Milchsäurebakterien produzieren Essigsäure und Milchsäure und machen das ganze System sauer. Je nachdem kann man steuern, aber wenn man es einfach nur stehen lässt, vielleicht auch noch kalt, dann wird es relativ sauer. Und deshalb nennt sich das Ding Sauerteig.
Das heißt, das bildet sich aus dem Getreide selbst heraus?
Genau, die Mikroorganismen schwirren überall durch die Gegend, die hängen hier an der Luft, an der Wand, an deiner Haut und eben auch an Getreidekörnern oder auch an Apfelschalen, alles überall. Vor allem an Früchten sind sie konzentriert, an den Schalen, an Rosinen, an Datteln, Feigen und eben auch an Getreidekörnern. Und wenn du jetzt das Getreide aufmahlst, dann hast du die Viecher, ich nenne die immer schätzt das Viecher oder Tierchen, sind einfach nur Bakterien oder Pilze, hast du die in deinem Brei drin und die fangen sich an zu vermehren. Wenn es schön warm ist, geht das effektiver, schneller, je mehr Wasser im Spiel ist es auch.
Warm und feucht, genau.
Genau. Und dann hast du irgendwann eine kritische Masse an Mikroorganismen, die das Mehl verstoffwechseln, vor allem die Stärke, also das Weiße im Korn. Und das Mehl wird in den Zucker umgewandelt und letzten Endes ist der Zucker dann wiederum in CO2, Kohlendioxid. Und dieses Kohlendioxid lockert dir den Teig oder den Brei. Wenn jetzt noch einer herkommt und das Ganze mindestens trocknet in der Sonne oder besser noch bäckt bei hohen Temperaturen, dann hast du das erste gelockerte Brot. Und das ist nach archäologischen Funden bislang irgendwo bei dreieinhalbtausend vor Christus datiert. Sowohl in Ägypten als auch in der Schweiz, in der heutigen Schweiz.
Ägypten und der Schweiz. Also können die Ägypter jetzt nicht behaupten, sie wären die einzigen Erfinder.
Das können sie schon bei vielen anderen Sachen aber nicht.
Die Pyramiden lassen wir euch. Okay, verstehe. Also man nimmt das Getreide, man macht Wasser, man nimmt Wärme und der Rest ist sozusagen einfach da und man lässt es halt einfach geschehen. Die Kunst ist natürlich dann, wie beim Bier ja auch, das Ganze quasi kontrolliert geschehen zu lassen und im richtigen Zeitpunkt, bevor sich alles selber auffrisst und dann irgendwie zu überhaupt nichts Guten mehr führt, in dem Moment einfach die Hitze hinzuzufügen, die am Anfang halt einfach, was weiß ich, flache Steine waren wahrscheinlich, die in der Sonne lagen oder die Feuer dann halt irgendwann...
Also die ersten Fladenbrote sind einfach Trockenbrote gewesen, tatsächlich in der Sonne getrocknet und Feuer gibt es auch schon eine gewisse Weile, das gab es auch schon, als Brei gegessen wurde und dann ist es natürlich leicht, diesen Brei irgendwo auf einem heißen Stein zu packen im Ofen oder im Feuer einfach einen Stein ins Feuer legen und den heiß werden lassen und dann da drauf oder in der Asche gebacken, geht auch.
Mit sowas geht ja dann eigentlich auch mal so eine gewisse technische Entwicklung dann mit, also sowas wie ein Backofen stand dann ja auch irgendwie an, also man muss ja, muss man ja auch erstmal, muss man auch erstmal sich ausdenken.
Ja, wobei ich denke, das ist dann gar nicht mehr so ein großer Schritt, wenn du einmal das Feuer hast und weißt, dein Brei lockert sich oder weckt zumindest im Feuer und du möchtest nicht die ganze Asche drum rum haben, wenn du es in die Asche, in die Glut legst, dann legst du halt einen Stein ins Feuer und irgendwann ist der Weg so weit, dass du einfach durch logisches Denken, das konnten die damals sicherlich auch, sagst, oben kommt die kalte Luft ran, mache ich mir ein Gewölbeturm rum, ist das System geschlossen. Packt das Feuer in das Gewölbe und das Brot gleichzeitig rein oder nehme erst mal die Glut raus, dass nur noch die Steine heiß sind und packt da dann meinen Brei, meinen Teig rein.
Also die wird man ja auch gefunden haben, nämlich mal an solche alten Backen.
Ja, also die alten Ägypter haben schon im groß technischen Stil Brot gebacken für die Arbeiter, die die Pyramiden dann gebaut haben.
Die müssen ja auch durch irgendwas gepowert werden.
Genau, also das waren die ersten Großbäckereien, die es gab, zu ägyptischen Zeiten. Die Römer hatten auch schon relativ große Bäckereien. Die haben auch zig Tonnen Brot pro Tag produziert. Also ist das die Entwicklung, die wir heute haben, letzten Endes keine neue Geschichte, aber in einem gewissen Sinne doch anders, was industrielle Backwaren angeht.
Also kann man im Prinzip sagen, dass so dieses Brotbacken überhaupt schon so die erste automatisierte Massen-Lebensmittel-Herstellung war?
Ob es die erste war, weiß ich nicht, aber es war zumindest eine. Dann aber so gedacht, dass was einer machen kann. Also wenn du ein Brot backst, passierte damals das Gleiche mit 10.000 Leuten. Also dann gibt es nicht einen der Brot backst, sondern dann machen 10.000 Leute das Gleiche. Da ist noch Kraft dahinter. Also Manneskraft, Frauenkraft dahinter. Heute siehst du in einer großen Halle nur noch ein, zwei Leute, die die Anlagen überwachen. Und alles andere läuft automatisiert. Das ist eine komplett andere Geschichte, als wenn du wegen 1.000 Leute hinstellst, die trotzdem noch handwerklich Brot backen.
Aber trotzdem, worauf ich hinaus will, das war auch etwas, wo man mit dem Aufwand weniger sehr viele Leute versorgen konnte, die dann wiederum die Zeit hatten, überhaupt erst mal was anderes zu tun. Im Vergleich zu Jäger, die vielleicht gerade mal genug haben, damit alle nicht sterben. Aber das waren jetzt keine Energieversorgungsmaschinen. Da konnte man froh sein, dass man überhaupt noch genug hatte. Während sich das Brot natürlich in Abhängigkeit von der Verfügbarkeit von Getreide, also der Größe des Anbaus und dem Glück im Anbau, das Wetter auch noch mit reinrechnet, wurde das, wie man im Computerkreis so schön sagt, das skaliert. Wenn man das dann irgendwie groß baut, dann gibt es halt genug Wege, dann eben auch sehr viele Leute zu versorgen. Also ich würde ja fast jetzt mal den Schluss rausziehen, das könnte dann auch eine der treibenden Kräfte gewesen sein, die dann überhaupt so eine große Kulturnation wie Ägypten in der Frühzeit ermöglicht hat. Und das war's schon, oder? Ich meine, sehr viel mehr muss man eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Letzten Endes ist die Geschichte damit so weit erzählt. Man konnte nur mit Sauerteig backen, wenn man ein lockeres Brot haben wollte. Und das blieb so, bis das Brauerei-Wesen so richtig anfing. Also bis man anfing, mit Bierhefen zu arbeiten. Dann geht quasi der nächste Schritt los, dass der Bäcker oder das Dorf, die Familie, mit Hefe arbeitet, nicht mehr nur mit Sauerteig, sondern mit Hefe. Dann fallen also die Milchsäurebakterien weg. Man lockert das Brot nur noch über die Hefe. Man hat also keine Säuerung mehr, sondern lediglich die Entwicklung von Kohlendioxid.
Also um es nochmal zusammenzukriegen, Sauerteig ist ja im Prinzip etwas, was von sich heraus entsteht, aus dem Getreide selbst. Man teilt sich dann immer was davon auf und nutzt sozusagen einen gewissen Vorrat, wo sich diese ganzen Milchsäurebakterien schon gebildet haben, um dann größere Mengen Brot damit wieder anzuwechseln?
Genau. Du hast ja einmal einen Sauerteig hergestellt, durch stehenlassendes Preis. Und du verbeckst nicht den gesamten Sauerteig, sondern nimmst immer was davon ab und hebst das auf.
Wie hält man das dann frisch genug?
Entweder wächst du täglich, dann hast du immer einen voll reifen Sauerteig, den du gleich wieder zum Ansetzen des nächsten Sauerteiges nehmen kannst. Oder du musst den irgendwie konservieren, das heißt kalt stellen oder trocknen oder relativ fest machen. Je weniger Wasser da im Spiel ist, umso langsamer arbeiten die Viecher.
Das heißt, das stirbt jetzt auch nicht ab, wenn es getrocknet ist?
Kommt darauf an, das Trocknen und auch Einfrieren sind die beiden extremen Varianten. Da geht relativ viel kaputt. Das kann funktionieren, muss nicht funktionieren, das wieder zum Leben zu erwecken. Also lieber kalt stellen, über 0 Grad, oder Wasser entziehen. Aber nicht so extrem wie komplett trocknen. Aber zurück zur Hefe. Der Sauerteig war das einzige Lockerungsmittel, was man hatte fürs Brot. Die Hefe kam erst ins Spiel, als die Brauereien angefangen haben, quasi Peer-Hefe abzuschöpfen.
Beziehungsweise musste man auch überhaupt erst mal herausfinden, dass diese Komponente mit drin ist, weil in dem Moment, wo die Hefe einfach nur so aus der Luft und von den Körnerschalen herbeigeflogen kam, hat sie ja nie jemand aktiv mit hinzugegeben. Also die war halt immer da, aber man wusste ja eigentlich gar nicht, dass sie da eine Rolle spielt. Das heißt, es ist dann erstmal auch eine wissenschaftliche Entdeckung sozusagen, dass man Hefen als solche überhaupt erst mal erkannt hat. Also vor welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Ja, da fragst du mich was.
Also wir sind jetzt nicht mehr in Ägypten auf jeden Fall.
Nee, nee, wir sind sicherlich im 11.12. Jahrhundert. Also weit ab von Ägypten. Die eigentliche Backhefe, so wie wir sie jetzt kennen, ist eine Geschichte des 19. Jahrhunderts erst. Und in dem Zeitraum, also ich sag mal, um die Mittelalterzeit bis ins 19. Jahrhundert rein, hat man hauptsächlich mit Sauerteig gebacken, hat ab und zu diese Bierhefe aus den Brauereien als Unterstützung genommen. Da entwickelten sich dann auch eigene Gebäckarten, die dann ohne Sauerteig gebacken werden, also die klassischen Brötchen, Weizenbrötchen. Aber alles mit relativ schlechten Ergebnissen, weil die Bierhefe nicht die Eigenschaft hat wie die heutige Backhefe. Es gibt eine alte Enzyklopädie, ich glaube, die ist von 1700 und noch was. Da beschreibt der Autor die Nachteile dieser Bierhefe mit nachlassenden Teig-Eigenschaften, schlechter Aromen im Brot und empfiehlt, wenn man die Wahl hat, tatsächlich immer noch mit Sauerteig zu backen als mit der Bierhefe aus den Brauereien. Erst als die Brauer das Brauverfahren umgestellt haben, da kenne ich mich aber, wenn ich aus bin, keiner, der Alkohol trinkt und auch kein Bier. Auf jeden Fall von obergärig auf untergärig, sodass man die Hefe nicht mehr so einfach wegnehmen konnte, fingen die Holländer an, Bäckerhefe selbst herzustellen, nur für die Aquan-Produktion. Dieses Verfahren ist dann über die Grenze geschwappt nach Deutschland und erst seitdem gibt es die Bäckerhefe, wie wir sie kennen. Das ist irgendwo um 19. Jahrhundert rum gewesen.
Wie wird die hergestellt? Was für ein Prozess wurde dort gerade?
Du brauchst natürlich mindestens eine Hefezelle aus einem bestimmten Stamm, die du dir selektierst nach bestimmten Eigenschaften. Das Ziel ist dann, diese Hefezelle zu vermehren. Das geht tatsächlich auch heute noch so, dass du in der Petrischale anfängst, die in der Petrischale vermehrst, und dich dann immer steigerst. Das geht mindestens exponentiell. Dann geht es in den Tank und in ein großes Silo, und irgendwann hast du eine riesige Menge an Nährstoffen dabei, wie Zucker, Melasse, der Grundrohrstoff ist Melasse, ein Rückstand aus der Zuckergewinnung. Dann kommt Phosphate rein und Nitrate und diverse Mittel, um das Ganze wieder zu entschäumen. Und die Hefe wieder abzutrennen. Das ist ein sehr ungünstiges Verfahren, was die konventionelle Hefe angeht, mit relativ viel Abfall, der als Sondermittel entsorgt werden muss.
Was für ein Abfall ist das?
Das sind speziell diese Phosphate und Nitrate. Das sind die Phosphorverbindungen, Stickstoffverbindungen. Das führte dann wieder dazu, dass es auch eine Gegenbewegung gab mit der Biohefe, die dann auf natürlichen Rohstoffen passiert. Mittlerweile auch auf Melasse, dann auch auf Bio Melasse. Die ersten Hersteller haben das auf Getreidebasis gemacht. Also Getreide, enzymatisch auf natürlichem Wege, in Zucker umgewandelt. Und der Zucker war dann wieder die Nahrung für die Hefe. Im Prinzip ist aber das Verfahren das gleiche. Die Hefen brauchen irgendwas, um sich zu vermehren. Also Mineralstoffe und Zucker. Und vermehren sich dann. Und am Ende presst man das in einen Würfel. Oder verarbeitet das noch trockener zu Pellets und hat dann die Trockenhefe.
Das ist ja das, was man auch heute noch im Supermarkt erstellt. Die kleinen Hefewürfel. Okay, also das hat quasi die Holländer damit angefangen, weil sie einfach gesehen haben, das ist jetzt eine super Alternative zum Sauerteig. Eine Alternative insofern, ist der Prozess mit dem Sauerteig schwieriger zu handeln gewesen? Oder waren die Ergebnisse dann nicht so vielfältig? Also was hat jetzt tatsächlich zu diesem Durchbruch geführt, dass man sagt, ich mach doch das lieber richtig mit Hefe, anstatt da irgendwie darauf zu warten, dass mein Teig vor sich hin blubbert? Ist das so Zeitersparnis?
Das ist der wichtigste Punkt, die Zeit. Wenn du mit Sauerteig arbeitest, brauchst du relativ viel Zeit, um den Teig so reif zu kriegen, wie er sein soll.
Weil er sich ja quasi aus diesem abgetrennten Sauerteigteil, der eine Weile gebraucht hat, sich zu entwickeln, muss das ja dann sozusagen in den anderen Teig dann auch erstmal richtig übergehen. Das dauert und bei der Hefe geht es schneller.
Die Hefe ist schneller, das ist die richtige Aussage. Und beim Sauerteig dauert es aus verschiedenen Gründen länger. Der erste Grund ist, dass du die Hefe nicht so konzentriert hast in dem Sauerteig wie in deinem Hefewürfel. Das heißt, es dauert einfach länger, bis die Hefen so viel Gas produziert haben, wie es ein Würfel auf einem halben Kilometer täte. Und der zweite Grund ist, du hast immer noch nicht Säure dabei. Wenn du das Ganze zu stark dosierst, also zu viel Sauerteig in deinen Brotteig gibst, dann hast du ein Brot, das relativ sauer schmeckt. Oder wenn du den Teig falsch kalt führst, dann ist mehr Säure drin, als wenn du ihn warm führst. Das ist dann wiederum eine Geschmacksfrage. Führen heißt, du hast bestimmte Temperaturbedingungen und Zeitbedingungen und steckst da deinen Teig hinein in diese Schraube. Also bezeichne den Prozess, den Ablauf. Der Prozess vom Teigmischen bis zum Verbacken des Teiges.
Okay, also die Hefe war einfach praktischer Tat. Dasselbe oder Vergleichbare, aber in kürzerer Zeit. Man konnte diese Hefe quasi schon industriell oder zumindest hochautomatisiert zentral herstellen, verteilen. Und damit bot man den Bäckern oder wer auch immer gebacken hat, eine ganz andere Möglichkeit, Teige heranzuziehen und damit auch größere Mengen in kürzerer Zeit herzustellen.
Genau, das war auch sicherer als der Sauerteig. Der Sauerteig muss gut gepflegt sein und es ist auch, je nachdem wie man ihn pflegt, anfällig für äußere Einflüsse, also für andere Mikroorganismen. Die Hefe ist so konzentriert in ihrem Dasein, dass da von außen kaum was ran kann. Wie kann man es vergleichen? Ja, vielleicht ist es einfacher, Luxemburg zu überfallen als Frankreich. Und Frankreich wäre jetzt der Hefewürfel und Luxemburg der Sauerteig. Also du kannst eine kleine Gruppe, je nach Führungsart halt auch relativ instabile Gruppe von Mikroorganismen von außen stärker beeinflussen mit anderen Mikroorganismen als wenn du eine stabile Kultur hast, die auch sehr selektiert ist, wo also nur eine Gruppe von Mikroorganismen drinsteckt. Und das war in dem Falle eine bestimmte Hefeart.
Der Sauerteig ist das Dorf und die Hefe ist die Burg, sozusagen.
Genau.
Nicht so leicht einzunehmen.
Also es ist einfach eine Zeitersparnis und es gibt mehr Sicherheit dem Baggergebnis gegenüber. Hat auch Nachteile, über die können wir auch noch reden. Die Hefewelle, die da über das Land geschwappt ist, die schwappt momentan gerade so über die etwas weniger entwickelten Länder im osteuropäischen Raum. Das haben wir schon alles hinter uns. Wir entwickeln uns gerade wieder zurück Richtung Sauerteig in Deutschland, Österreich, Schweiz. Ich war vor einem Jahr in Albanien. Da beckt man bis heute noch auf dem Land mit Weizensauerteig ausschließlich. Und in den großen Städten, Tirana zum Beispiel, schwappt schon die Hefewelle übers Land.
Aus denselben Gründen.
Man kann schneller backen. Man bekommt aber eben auch Gebäcke, die nicht mehr so schmecken und auch nicht mehr so frisch halten wie mit Sauerteig gebacken.
Was macht denn den Sauerteig so resistent in der Hinsicht? Was ist sozusagen jetzt der Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden Backerzeugnissen? Das eine vom Sauerteig getrieben, das andere von der Hefe getrieben? Also Hefe geht schneller, wissen wir.
Hefe geht immer schneller. Muss nicht immer schneller gehen, das kommt auf die Hefedosis an, aber die meisten Bäcker und auch Autonomalverbraucher nehmen viel Hefe, damit es möglichst schnell geht. Das ist eine Frage der Lagerkapazität in der Bäckerei. Wenn ich einen Teig lange lagern muss, dann brauch ich mehr Platz. Und das kostet wieder. Und ich hab mehr Aufwand etc. Aber davon ab, der Sauerteig hat die Säure in sich. Deshalb heißt das so. Die Säure bringt neben dem Geschmack auch noch eine längere Frischhaltung. Sie konserviert das Brot, schützt also das Brot vor äußeren Einflüssen, vor Schimmelsporen zum Beispiel. Die können nicht so wirken in einem Sauerteigbrot wie in einem nichtgesäuerten Brot. Das andere sind Fragen der Bekömmlichkeit. Das Sauerteigbrot ist immer bekömmlicher, also für den Damen besser verwertbar als ein Hefebrot, liegt auch wieder an den Säuren. Die Säuren aktivieren oder beschleunigen Reaktionen, enzymatische Reaktionen im Teig, die bestimmte Bestandteile des Getreidekornes aufschließen, die wir ansonsten gar nicht verarbeiten könnten. Oder im Gegenteil, die uns noch Mineralstoffe entziehen. Das ist eher eine Frage, dass die Tierrichtung Vollkorn geht. Der Sauerteig an sich, kann man ganz pauschal sagen, ist immer besser als ein Brot, das nur mit Hefe gebacken ist.
Also besser im Sinne von, was du gerade gesagt hast. Es hält länger, es bereitet quasi das Getreide im Brot auf eine Art und Weise vor, dass es für den Körper besser zu verarbeiten ist.
Der Sauerteig verdaut das Getreide schon einmal vor. Das was die Kuh in mehreren Etappen macht, in mehreren Mägen macht. Genau, wieder hochwirkt und dann erst ist, machen wir normalerweise mit Sauerteig. Der Sauerteig ist unser externer Magen.
Interessanter Blick auf die Sache. Das heißt, Hefe ist so ein bisschen der Feind, oder ist das jetzt ein bisschen...
Nicht unbedingt, man kann auch ein sehr gutes und sehr bekümmerliches Hefebrot backen, wenn man darauf achtet, dass die Hefemenge in einem gewissen Rahmen bleibt.
Okay, also man muss das sozusagen... Ist ja immer dasselbe beim Essen. Schaden kann alles, ist immer eine Frage der Dosierung und der richtigen Zubereitung.
Also das, was ein Hefebrot in aller Regel nicht so günstig macht für den Körper, ist weniger die Hefe, sondern die Zeit, die ihm fehlt.
Okay, ich fasse das mal zusammen. Also im Prinzip haben wir jetzt so zwei Entwicklungen, die Urentwicklung des Brotes, quasi die Entdeckung, dass, wenn man diesen Brei lange genug stehen lässt, dass sich dort halt Milchsäuren und Essigsäuren bilden, die dann mit diesem Brei quasi so eine Einheit ergeben, die, wenn man die dann eben zu einem richtigen Teig anmengt, sich halt gut backen lässt, weil eben diese Mischung CO2 freigibt und damit quasi alles auflockert. Also es wird quasi, es bläst sich förmlich von innen auf. Und das macht das Brot dann an der Stelle natürlich bekömmlicher oder einfacher zu konsumieren, sag ich mal.
Genau, darum geht's.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein praktischer Nebeneffekt, dass man einfach diese Masse und diese Luftigkeit erzeugt. Und das ist ja irgendwie auch so eine der attraktiven Dinge von Brot. Man gibt natürlich auch Knäckebrot-Fans, aber man will ja nicht immer nur so Keksbrot in sich reinschieben. Später kam dann quasi die Erkenntnis, aha, da sind auch noch andere Dinge mit dem Spiel, die wir so vielleicht bisher noch gar nicht gesehen haben. Diese Hefen, die schon auch immer irgendwie eine Rolle gespielt haben, auch in dem Sauerteil. Das ist ja nicht hefefrei. Die waren auch dabei und haben wahrscheinlich so irgendeinen kleinen Parameter in dieser Gesamtgleichung auch noch mit ausgefüllt. Aber in dem Moment, wo man die Hefen als solche auch biologisch verstanden hat, so weit, dass man sie auch produzieren konnte, waren sie dann auf einmal diese Wunderwaffe, weil sie sich schnell erzeugen ließen, weil man sie dann schnell distributieren konnte und dann eben auch sehr schnell noch größere Mengen an Brot erzeugen könnte, die ja auch luftig waren und dann sogar auch noch ein bisschen luftiger als der Sauerteig, weil, nicht unbedingt, aber okay, also mindestens vergleichbare, also vom Gefühl her vergleichbare Teige erzeugt hat und damit dann auch Brote, was man ihm gesagt hat, okay, ist doch eigentlich alles viel toller, nur dass man dann irgendwann feststellen muss, okay, Sauerteigbrot mag so seine.
Die Hefe ja nur aus einer Kultur besteht. Also wir haben quasi nur dich im Würfel und nicht halt Berlin. Im Sauerteig, zumindest wenn es ein traditionell geführter Sauerteig ist, der so wirklich per Zufall zusammen gemixt ist von den mikropiellen Dingen her, hat dann halt Berlin oder ganz Berlin im System, im Teig.
Höhere Diversität.
Man kann auch, und das machen relativ viele Bäcker, sogenannten Reinzucht-Sauerteig kaufen von einer Handvoll von Firmen. Das ist dann so eine Art Hefewürfel als Sauerteig. Also sehr selektiert mit einer bestimmten Menge an Mikroorganismen, an Milchsäurebakterien und Hefepilzen. Und das ist dann, wenn man es wieder als Bild ausdrücken möchte, ein Chor, wo vielleicht fünf Musiker, also fünf Sänger, mitsingen und das andere, der sogenannte Spontan-Sauerteig, wäre dann ein Chor, wo hundert Leute mitsingen. Also das klingt deutlich komplexer, deutlich schöner, schmeckt also besser und ist immer das, wofür ich brenne und wofür ich Werbung mache. Auch bei Bäckern kauft keine Reinzuchtkulturen zu, sondern macht euren eigenen Spontan-Sauerteig.
Ja, aber könnte man nicht bei der Hefe auch verschiedene Hefen mischen oder ist das etwas, wo sich die Hefen nicht so...
Kann man tun. Im Sauerteig hast du ja auch zig verschiedene Hefe-Arten, die mitspielen. Die eine agiert ein bisschen stärker als die andere, aber alle spielen irgendwie mit im Gesamtkonzert. Von den Winzern her weiß ich, dass die angefangen haben, wieder mit wilden Hefen zu experimentieren. Da gibt es ja auch Weinhäfen, die genauso wie die Würfelhefe vorgezogen, vorselektiert sind und man fängt wieder an, mit wilden Hefen zu arbeiten. Und das Gleiche kann man auch im Brot tun. Also man kann tatsächlich auch...
Die Hefen, die dann für den Gärprozess des Weines...
Genau, man kann tatsächlich auch sich Hefen einfangen, ohne die Milchsäurebakterien dazu zu haben und damit dann ein Brot lockern. Und das schmeckt dann natürlich immer anders, je nachdem, welche Art von Hefe man sich da eingezogen hat.
Worüber wir noch gar nicht so richtig gesprochen haben jetzt in dem Zusammenhang ist, also wir haben jetzt die Hefe, wir haben den Sauerteig, aber wie viel hängt denn von dem Getreide selbst ab? Also wir hatten ja jetzt ursprünglich erst mal gesagt, da gab es halt so Gräser, das sind dann halt irgendwann Kulturpflanzen geworden, in verschiedenster Ausprägung. Der Weizen, sicherlich auch heute noch am bedeutendsten. Was kommt noch so zum Einsatz? Gerste, Roggen, Hafer?
Ja, also die Grundlegenden sind Weizen und Roggen. Und zu Weizen zählen dann ganz viele verschiedene andere Geschichten. Einkorn, Ema, Dinkel zählen alles mit zur großen Gruppe von Weizen. Gerste ist ein Thema. Gerste zählt zu den sogenannten nicht wachfähigen Getreiden, weil sie kein eigenes Teiggerüst aufbauen kann, wie es Weizen oder Roggen kann. Man kann sie zumischen, aber ein reines Gerstenbrot ist nicht wirklich möglich. Dazu kommen dann auch noch andere Sachen, eben Buchweizen zum Beispiel. Klingt wie Weizen, ist aber kein wachfähiges Getreide, gehört auch nicht zur Weizenfamilie.
Heißt nur so.
Heißt nur so. Und andere Geschichten. Das sind alles Pseudogetreide. Also Gerste ist schon ein Getreide, aber kein wachfähiges Getreide. Buchweizen wären Pseudogetreide, weil es gar nicht zur Familie der Süßgräser gehört. Alles, was Getreide heißt, gehört zur Familie der Süßgräser. Und alles, was da nicht reingehört, nennt man Pseudogetreide, weil es unter Umständen so verwendet wird wie ein Getreide.
Süßgräser wegen des Zuckergehalts quasi, der in ihnen schlummert, potenziell.
Genau. Also du hast die Stärke in den Körnern drin und die Stärke ist letztendlich ein Kohlenhydrat, was zu Zucker abgebaut werden kann. Also wir backen in unseren Gefilden hier, also im deutschsprachigen Raum, mit Roggen und mit Weizen. Klammerauf zu Weizen zählen dann eben auch die klassischen Sachen, die man so mit Urgetreide verbindet, Einkorn, Eimer, Dinkel.
Und was wurde jetzt genommen von diesen Körnern, also was wurde genommen von den Pflanzen, um wirklich das Mehl herzustellen, um daraus den Teig herzustellen?
Die Getreidekörner, die Pflanze selbst besteht ja aus dem Halm und aus den Blättern. Und dann hast du die Ähre. Also da in der Ähre gibt es verschiedene Ährenarten, die verschieden aufgebaut sind. Es gibt einkörnige Ähren, das wäre dann eben ein Korn, da ist dann nur eine Blüte pro Spindel, pro Ebene in der Ähre. Dann gibt es Emma, das wäre das Zweikorn, da hast du schon zwei, also mehr Ertrag am Ende. Emma, das ist das sogenannte Zweikorn. Und dann geht das weiter. Du kannst auch vier Körner pro Ebene haben, oder manchmal sogar sechs. Das ist natürlich für den Anbau dann effektiver. Und aus diesen Ährchen schieben sich Blüten, und wenn die bestäubt sind, entwickeln sich daraus irgendwann die Körner. Und diese Körner hat man verwendet, über verschiedene Verfahren natürlich erstmal aus der Ähre rausgetroschen und entspelzt. Unter Umständen gibt es um die Körner ist dann unter Umständen noch eine Hüllschicht, ein Hüllblatt, der spälzt, beim Dinkel zum Beispiel. Und bei Weizen ist er nicht in der Form da. Also er fällt ab, beim Dinkel ist er fest. Der muss also in einem separaten Arbeitsgang nochmal entfernt werden vom Dinkelkorn. So oder so, irgendwann hast du das Korn, und das Korn ist aufgemahlen worden. Am Anfang einfach mit einem Stein auf einen anderen Stein gerieben und mittlerweile in sehr komplexen Verfahren, in Mühlen. Was von jeher gemacht wurde, ist, dass man versucht hat, die Schale des Korns vom Mähkörper zu drehen, also von dem Innenleben des Korns.
Das wurde schon immer gemacht?
Ja, also man hat auch schon zu ägyptischen Zeiten entweder über sogenannte Windsichtung, also das gemahlene Gut oder das Korn nach oben geworfen, um die Kleie, die Schale wegwehen zu lassen oder einfach durch Sieben, im nicht heutigen Sinne, sondern man hat einfach einen Beutel genommen, mehr oder weniger dicht gewebt und hat dann durch die Maschen des Gewebes, das Weiße, also das eigentliche Mehl rieseln lassen und die Kleie, die Schale blieb im Beutel und war dann letztendlich das Viehfutter und das war schon immer Viehfutter. Diese ganze Vollkornwelle, die es seit den 70er, 80er Jahren gibt, ist tatsächlich ein modernes Phänomen. Also man hat früher in äußerst Notzeiten die Schale mitgegessen und mitzugemischt, um überhaupt was im Magen zu haben, aber wenn man konnte, hat man einen Großteil der Schale entfernt, weil die Schale für uns selbst nicht wirklich verdaubbar verwertbar ist.
Das sind diese Ballaststoffe sozusagen?
Die Ballaststoffe sind an sich gut, da sind aber auch noch andere Stoffe drin. Da komme ich jetzt wieder zum Sauerteig zurück, die uns eher schaden als nutzen, wenn wir sie nicht richtig verarbeiten. Und das hat man natürlich früher auch gemerkt, wenn du Vollkornbrei isst, dann liegt der dir im Magen. Auch Vollkornbrot, wenn es falsch verarbeitet ist, liegt dir im Magen. Und du hast eher Sorgen damit, dass du was Sinnvolles von hast.
Das heißt, man wollte eigentlich immer nur den Kern des Kerns haben? Genau.
Man hat versucht, die Schale abzutrennen und an den Mehlkörper ranzukommen. Da ist die Stärke drin, das Eiweiß und andere Ballaststoffe beim Rocken, die ein Gerüst aufbauen können, die dann das Gas auffangen. Du hast immer ein lockeres Gebäck gekriegt, wenn du die Schale abgetrennt hast, als wenn du sie im Mehl gelassen hast.
Und warum muss dann auf einmal alles Vollkorn sein, wenn da eigentlich so viel drin ist, was man gar nicht so gut verarbeiten kann?
Es gab eine Handvoll von Wissenschaftlern, die herausgefunden haben, dass die Ballaststoffe sehr gut sind für den Darm, die Darmtätigkeit anregen, vor Krankheiten schützen und natürlich dann auch Mineralstoffe liefern, wenn es passend verarbeitet ist und auch Vitamine. Die haben publiziert, verschiedene Bücher und haben da so eine Welle losgetreten. Die Originalpublikationen sind meistens auch so gestrickt, dass es Sinn macht, was da steht. Nur im Nachgang ist das ein bisschen verwässert worden. Zum Beispiel Frischkornbrei heißt du, du mahst deinen Korn und mischst es mit Wasser an und rein damit. Es gab von den Originalpublikationen aus den 80er Jahren Empfehlungen, die weit unter denen lagen, was deren Jünger empfohlen haben. Das führte letztendlich dazu, dass diejenigen, die massiv Vollkorn gegessen haben und falsch zubereitet, also falsch zubereitet heißt, nicht gequollen lassen, nicht erhitzt, nicht gekeimt oder nicht mit Sauerteig verarbeitet, dass diejenigen eher Mangelerscheinungen haben, auf lange Sicht. Da gibt es Studien drüber. Wer über 10, 15 Jahre relativ ungünstig Vollkorn gegessen hat, also falsch verarbeitet, hat Mangelerscheinungen an Mineralstoffen, an Vitaminen. Bei den Substanzen, die da in der Schale stecken, unter anderem Mineralstoffe auch entziehen können aus dem Körper.
Wie unangenehm eigentlich.
Das ist unangenehm. Die haben schon die Mineralstoffe in sich, binden die aber so stark, dass der Körper nicht rankommt, wenn man nicht über diese vier Wege, Quellen, Hitze, Keimen oder Sauerteig geht und diese Stoffe freisetzt.
Ah, verstehe. Also da ist sozusagen viel Gutes drin, aber es würde jetzt einfach weitgehend unbehandelt, eher Schaden als Nützen, weil es nicht her und schafft zusätzliche Probleme, weil das dann unbehandelt, also die ziehen dann sozusagen auch noch selber das an. Also sie wollen dann sozusagen noch mehr Mineralien haben, diese Stoffe, ohne dass man sie selber nutzen kann.
Genau, das ist eine Stoffgruppe, die das tut. Und was du immer hast, wenn du vollkommen bist, die Ballaststoffe, die tun dir immer gut oder auch nicht. Das kommt auf den jeweiligen Menschen an, ob der Darm das verträgt oder nicht. Die meisten vertragen es und den meisten tut es auch gut, drückt die Darmtätigkeit an und soll vor verschiedenen Krankheiten schützen. Darmkrebs zum Beispiel ist relativ gesichert sogar, dass es das tut. Aber dann gibt es eben noch die anderen Punkte, die darf man halt nicht außer Acht lassen. Ballaststoffe ist gut und schön, wenn das Vollkornbrot meint, wegen der aber Mineralstoffe entzieht, dann hast du wieder eine negative Seite. Man kann es halt nicht losgelöst betrachten, nur auf eine Gruppe an Inhaltsstoffen, sondern man muss irgendwie das Gesamte betrachten. Da gibt es verschiedene Wege, um doch was vom vollen Korn zu haben. Wenn man es einfach nur so isst, ohne dass man es zum Beispiel vorverdaut in Form des Sauerteiges, hat man eher weniger davon.
Das heißt, der Sauerteig hat auch die noch schlechter gemahlenen frühen Mele, die noch das komplette Korn, also das Vollkorn genommen haben, im Prinzip auch erträglich gemacht durch eben diesen Sauervorprozess. Das ist wahrscheinlich einer dieser Vorprozesse, die du vorhin meintest, dass quasi der Sauerteig das eben macht. Deswegen war es damals noch nicht so ein großes Problem, aber dann spätestens mit den Hilfe-basierten Methoden war es dann wahrscheinlich extra wichtig, dass man dann wirklich relativ feine Mele hat, die den Kern weglassen.
Ja, man hat ja auch spätestens, seit die Hilfe da war und man helle Gebäckchen gebacken hat, hat man auch versucht, tatsächlich helles Mehl zu haben, ohne Schalenanteil. Das ist dann bei uns das 50er-Weizen-Mehl zum Beispiel. Da ist keine Spur von Schale mehr, fast keine Spur von Schale mehr drin. Man kennt ja so, das hat man im Hinterkopf abgespeichert, die Reichen haben immer das Helle gegessen und die Armen das Dunkle. Also mit Dunkel verbindet man dann immer Vollkorn. Was Dunkel und hell ausmacht, geht es da eher um Weizen und im Roggen. Weizen war ein Mehl der Reichen, weil es relativ ertragsschwach war und nicht so weit verbreitet in unseren Gefilden im Anbau. Also auch relativ teuer aufwändig herzustellen.
Weizen war ertragsschwach im Vergleich zu Roggen.
Liegt an den Böden. Damals gab es nicht die Bodenstruktur und also nicht den Bodenaufbau und auch nicht die Anbaumöglichkeiten für Weizen, wie es die heute gibt, und auch nicht die Sortenauswahl. Deutschland war ein Roggenland. Man hat Roggen angebaut, der wächst fast überall. Der ist relativ unempfindlich gegen Witterungsbedingungen, gegen verschiedene Bodenqualitäten. Und deshalb hat man Roggen angebaut. Roggen war relativ billig und eben auch dunkler als Weizen. Daher kommt das. Also die arme Bevölkerung hat dunkle Backwaren gegessen, weil sie mit Roggen gebacken haben und nicht unbedingt weil Vollkorn im Spiel war.
Verstehe.
Der Schalenanteil war sicherlich höher als bei den Reichen mit Weizen. Auch das Roggenmehl wurde gebeutelt. Also in einen Beutel gesteckt und durchgesiebt.
Okay, verstehe. Wir sind ein Roggenland.
Nicht mehr, nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr, aber waren wir auf jeden Fall.
Wir waren es. Im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern sind wir immer noch ein Roggenland. Aber der Weizen hat dem Roggen den Rang abgelaufen.
Das heißt, Roggen ist ein europäisches oder ein deutsches Phänomen gewesen?
Ein osteuropäisches Phänomen. Also auch alles, was östlich von Deutschland liegt, ist eher rockenbetont gewesen.
Was einfach nur mit der Zusammensetzung der Böden zu tun hat.
Ja, und auch mit der Verbreitung des Getreides. Roggen war ursprünglich ein Unkraut im Weizen. Also man hat es immer als Beikraut gehabt und hat dann irgendwann probiert, das auch zu nutzen und züchterisch weiterzuentwickeln. Sämtliche Getreidearten, wie wir sie kennen, also Ema, Einkorn, Dinkel, Weizen, Norgens, kommen alle so aus der Ecke des fruchtbaren Halbmondes. Das ist so ab Ägypten bis bis Iran und noch ein Stückchen weiter. In der Zone ist der Ursprung allen Übels, allen Getreides. Das hat sich dann so langsam über verschiedene Wege, je nach Getreideart, nach Europa ausgebreitet. Und eben Roggen über Osteuropa nach Deutschland. Deshalb sind das auch die klassischen Länder, wo es Roggen gibt. Wenn du in den USA nach Roggen suchst, dann findest du schon auch Roggen. Aber der hat bei Weitem nicht die Qualität und die Backeigenschaften, wie bei uns. Also wir sind züchterisch deutlich weiter, einfach über die Historie, als es ein Land, die die USA wäre.
Wobei, heutzutage könnte man ja sagen, prima Roggen, den bauen wir uns bei uns jetzt auch einfach an. Aber das funktioniert jetzt nicht so, weil dann wieder die Böden nicht so mit der Pflanze zusammengehen.
Zum Beispiel. Und dann davon ab, ist die USA einfach ein Weizenland.
Wenn du dir ein Roggenbrot hinlegst, wissen die nichts mit anzufangen.
Gibt es wahrscheinlich Schwierigkeiten.
Da kommt dann noch diese ganzen kulturellen Phänomene mit rein. Okay, also Roggen und Weizen sind sozusagen die Hauptgetreidearten. Roggen hat sich so auf dem zweiten Platz neben dem Weizen durchgeboxt und hat sich dann als sehr viel geeigneter zumindest, jetzt in diesen mittelosteuropäischen Bereichen gezeigt als Quelle. Und war dann der Lieferant für die dunklen Mele, Weizen, die hellen Mele. Und alle haben sich aber im Wesentlichen viel Mühe gegeben, um diese Körner loszuwerden.
Die Schale, genau.
Die Schale, natürlich die Schale loszuwerden von den Körnern. Und dieser Vollkorn-Trend war, wann sagtest du nochmal, ist das irgendwie losgegangen?
1970er, 1980er Jahren.
Also wirklich noch ein relativ frisches Phänomen. Einfach auf der Basis von diesen wissenschaftlichen Studien, dass man gesagt hat, naja, es ist nicht alles schlecht in der Schale des Kerns. Das kann auch durchaus von Vorteil sein, aber man muss halt extrem darauf achten, wie man das verarbeitet. Was muss man jetzt genau machen mit dieser Schale bei einem Vollkorn-Teig, damit es eben nicht diese ganzen negativen Eigenschaften mit sich bringt?
Das gibt vier Wege. Einer, den man selten will, ist, das Getreide keimen zu lassen, also einzuweichen und zu warten, dass da ein Spross rauskommt. Dann kann man es auch nicht mehr klassisch verarbeiten, sondern zu einem Mehl, wenn es andere Eigenschaften hat. Man kann daraus schon ein Brot backen, aber dann muss man ja tausend andere Sachen beachten. Also das können wir eigentlich schon mal wegschieben, wenn es um das Brotbacken geht. Dann bleiben noch drei Wege. Der erste Weg ist relativ simpel, Quellen lassen, also sprich Zeit lassen. Viel Zeit geben, den Teig lange ruhen lassen. Dann kommen Enzyme in Gang, die diese Giftstoffe, die die Pflanze gegen ihre Fraßfeinde produziert und in der Schale abspeichert, abbauen. Die Pflanze bringt alles mit, um die Stoffe wieder loszuwerden. Man muss den Stoffen nur Zeit geben, auch abgebaut zu werden.
Aber so muss man das ja auch verstehen. Die Schale ist ja quasi der Schutz vor dem Feind.
Genau.
Deswegen sind da Stoffe drin, die eigentlich erstmal den Angreifer in die Flucht schlagen sollen. Nach dem Motto ja, brauchst gar nicht das probieren, schmeckt eh nicht.
Und wir sind letzten Endes auch Angreifer.
Und denken uns lustige Methoden aus, um das dann zu umgehen. Also quellen lassen.
Also quellen lassen wäre die erste Taktik. Das ist immer eine gute Möglichkeit, auch aus geschmacklichen Gründen. Lange Reifezeiten für die Teige. Die zweite Taktik ist Hitze. Die haben wir sowieso beim Brotbacken. Und die dritte Taktik ist dann der Sauerteig. Also eine gewisse Säurekomponente in den Teig zu bringen. Weil ab einem bestimmten pH-Wert, also ab einer bestimmten Säuremenge im Teig, genau diese Enzyme in Gang kommen oder schneller arbeiten, die uns die Giftstoffe abbauen.
Okay, also entweder die Enzyme, die sozusagen aus Feuchtigkeit entstehen oder eben die ähnliche auch beim Sauerteig, halt die Säuren, die sich dann über die Giftstoffe hermachen. Und dann kann man auch Vollkorn essen. Dann ist es auch sinnvoll Vollkorn zu essen?
Genau, dann macht es auch Sinn. Aus Sicht der Ballaststoffe macht es immer Sinn, aber aus Sicht der Mineralstoffe, Vitamine und der Stoffe, die uns all das wegnehmen oder zumindest nicht freigeben, macht es tatsächlich Sinn, mit Sauerteig zu arbeiten.
Gut, jetzt brauchen wir ja ein Mehl. Wenn ich in so einem Supermarkt gehe, stehe ich da auch schon so ein bisschen blöd davor. Und denke mir so, welche Nummer darf es denn jetzt sein? Gibt es da immer diese Obscuren-500er-450er-Zahlen? Was macht diese Mehl jetzt noch so unterschiedlich, wenn sie dann doch alle aus derselben Quelle kommen?
Ja, fangen wir mit der Zahl an. Das lässt sich relativ einfach erklären. Im Supermarkt steht meistens 405er-Weizenmehl, 550er-Weizenmehl und vielleicht noch 1050er-Weizenmehl. Das bedeutet, dass zum Beispiel in einem 1050er-Weizenmehl ein Gramm Asche, schrägstrich Mineralstoffe, auf 100 Gramm Mehl enthalten sind. Also wenn du 100 Gramm Mehl aufbrennst bei 900 Grad, bleiben 1000 Mycogramm Asche übrig.
Asche im Sinne von nicht zu verwertender?
Nicht verbrennbare Bestandteile. Und nicht verbrennbar sind die Mineralstoffe, die wiederum hauptsächlich in der Schale stecken. Das heißt, wenn du eine Mehltüte hast, auf der eine sehr hohe Zahl steht, hast du mehr Schalenanteil im Mehl, als wenn du eine mit einer niedrigen Zahl hast. Ganz konkret, das 405er Weizenmehl kommt aus dem Kern des Kunsts, aus dem innersten Weißen. Da ist gar keine Schale mehr drin. Da hast du also extrem wenig Mineralstoffgeheit. Das sind 0,4 Gramm, exakt 0,405 Gramm.
Okay, also das ist quasi eine Milligramm-Anzahl.
Genau. Und wenn du dann immer auch wieder das andere Extrem, das Vollkornmehl hättest, dann gibt es gar keine Typenzahl, weil die Mineralstoffgeheit in Vollkornmehlen immer schwankt, je nachdem wie dick die Schale ist und wie groß das Korn geworden ist in der Erntephase. Aber das wäre so ungefähr bei 1600, 1700, 1800 Milligramm Asche in 100 Gramm Mehl. Also eine Type von 1700 zum Beispiel.
Und 550er gibt es aber jetzt auch, obwohl da jetzt mehr Schale drin ist. Das ist aber jetzt noch nicht gleich Vollkorn, sondern das ist...
Das ist noch weit ab von Vollkorn. 550er ist fast der gesamte Mehlklopper. Also wenn du die ganze Schale abpälst vom Korn, hast du ein weißes Inneres. Und das wäre ungefähr 550er Weizenmehl. Wie kommen wir zu diesen seltsamen Typen? Die Typen sind in Deutschland genormt über eine DIN.
Selbstverständlich.
Dann gibt es eine DIN. Und in der DIN steht ganz klar beschrieben, 550er Weizenmehl darf zwischen 0,5 und 0,62mg Asche enthalten. Auf eine bestimmte Menge an Mehl. Also der Müller hat eine Spannbreite. Der muss jetzt nicht exakt diese 550mg Mineralstoff einstellen. Auf die 100g Mehl, sondern er hat eine Spanne wiedergesponnen. Eben von 500 bis 620mg. Und was macht der Müller? Der Müller gibt seinen Korn in die Mühle zwischen zwei Metallwalzen. Das ist das gängige Verfahren, nennt sich Walzenstuhlverfahren. Zwei Metallwalzen, die drehen sich zur Mitte, also miteinander. Und eine schneller als die andere. Und wenn das Korn dann zwischen die zwei Walzen fällt, dann reißt es auf, weil eine Scherebewegung entsteht. Dann hat er, sehr schematisch ausgedrückt, zwei Hälften vom Korn, mit sehr viel Schale außen ran. Und aus den beiden Hälften krümelt ein bisschen Inneres raus. Unter den Walzen hat er dann eine Abfolge von Sieben, von grob nach fein. Und auf den groben Sieben bleibt das Schrot, also das grobe Korn, mit vielen Schalenbestandteilen dran. Und ganz unten krümelt so ein bisschen was an Mehl rein. Und in den Zwischensieben, in den Zwischengrößen, hat er dann den sogenannten Dunst. Das ist etwas gröber als Mehl. Und Kries ist noch gröber. So, jetzt kann er sagen, gefällt mir so, lass ich so. Dann hat er ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz wenig Mehl-Ausbeute unten, im untersten Sieb und ganz, ganz viel Schrot im obersten Sieb. Wäre gut, gefällt ihm aber normalerweise nicht, weil er Mehl produzieren möchte. Das heißt, er steckt die anderen Kornfraktionen, also von Dunst bis Schrot, nochmal oben rein. In den nächsten Durchlauf, in die nächste Passage. Und er stellt die Walzen ein bisschen enger. Er kriegt so schrittweise über 15 bis 20 Wiederholungen irgendwann das gesamte Korn auf eine Korngröße gemahlen, die nach deutschem Recht und Gesetz Mehl heißt. Und das heißt, es muss jedes Korn kleiner als 180 Mikrometer sein. Dann sprechen wir von Mehl.
Und darüber wäre es Dunst, und darüber wäre es Gris, und darüber wäre es Schrot.
Genau. Und wenn er das tut, arbeitet er sich ja von außen nach innen in das Korn vor über diese vielen verschiedenen Wiederholungen. Und hat jedes Mal eine bestimmte Menge Mehl und Dunst und Gris, kann er abtrennen, vor allem das Mehl trennt er ab. Und hat sozusagen dann Mehl aus verschiedenen Abteilen des Korns, auch mit verschiedenen Schalenanteilen, Mineralstoffgehalten. Das kann er alles separieren, in verschiedenen Silos lagern. Und am Ende will er meinetwegen 550er Weizenmehl herstellen. Dann kippt er all das, was er dann getrennt hat, in bestimmten Verhältnissen wieder zusammen. Oder auch nur bestimmte Silos, die zusammengeführt werden. Und hat dann am Ende 550er Weizenmehl. Das gleiche macht er mit 1050er Weizenmehl. Und auch selbst mit Vollkorn. Wenn er Vollkornmehl malen will, dann gibt er halt alles, was er vorher so mühsam separiert hat, am Ende wieder zusammen.
Das heißt Vollkorn, dann muss man sich davon trennen, dass man so nimmt das volle Korn und dann wird das einfach zerkleinert. Dann ist das Vollkornmehl. Sondern es wird alles erstmal komplett in seine kleinsten Bestandteile aufgeteilt, danach sortiert, wie klein diese Bestandteile tatsächlich sind. Und je nachdem, was man dann am Schluss haben will, mischt man sich quasi die einzelnen Bestandteile wieder zusammen.
Genau.
Weil es einfach prachtiger ist. Und weil man dann auch die definierten, die dienengenormten Anteile auch genau sicherstellt.
Also mit diesem Walzenstuhlverfahren, da steht noch nicht nur ein Walzenstuhl, sondern mehrere nebeneinander. Mit dem Walzenstuhlverfahren bist du in der Lage, diese Typen herzustellen, die Typenmehle. Und das Vollkornmehl könntest du natürlich, so ist das klassische Verfahren, einfach oben reinkippen, über zwei Mahlsteine schicken. Und dann hast du unten dein Vollkornmehl in einem Durchlauf. Geht aber eben bei dem Walzenstuhlverfahren nicht, weil das so ausgelegt ist, dass es erstmal das Korn zerpflückt, in verschiedene Passagen trennt, in verschiedene Bestandteile trennt. Und wenn er dann ausnahmsweise mal Vollkornmehl machen möchte, dann ist das ein heiden Aufwand, natürlich vorher gewesen, um es dann am Ende wieder zusammen zu kippen. Hat aber verschiedene Vorteile. Der größte Vorteil ist, dass er das Vollkornmehl sehr, sehr fein mahlen kann über diese Methode. Also auch die Schalen sehr fein gemahlen werden. Die kommen ja auch mit immer durch und werden feiner gemahlen. Wenn du es nur über zwei Mahlsteine schickst, kriegst du es nie so fein wie über den Walzenstuhl. Und Feinheit heißt auch immer gleich Lockerung. Je feiner dein Mehl ist, umso lockerer wird dein Brot am Ende.
Das heißt, nach dem ersten Durchgang hat man auf mehreren Sieben schon mal unterschiedliche Granularien sozusagen vorliegen. Kann danach auch schon bestimmen, woher es jetzt gekommen ist. Man muss ja unterscheiden zwischen drinnen und draußen. Das macht man dann quasi im ersten Schritt nach der Größe. Danach wird das dann sozusagen alles separat weiterverarbeitet. Also man nimmt die großen und macht die dann noch mal kleiner.
Genau. Du hast ein kleines bisschen Mehl nach der ersten Schrautung. Das trennst du ab, weil Mehl möchtest du ja machen.
Das ist dann das feine und das bleibt auch das feine.
Und dann kannst du als Müller sagen, ich möchte auch Dunst herstellen und Grieß. Dann trennst du es natürlich auch ab. Wenn du es nicht möchtest, dann kommt das wieder oben rein. Was immer reinkommt, ist das Schrot. Es gibt zum Beispiel in einer klassischen Mühle irgendwie zwischen drei und fünf Schrotungen. Da wird also erstmal das Schrot klein gemacht und dann geht es erst in die eigentlichen Mehlpassagen, wo dann das feine Schrot weiter zum Mehl verarbeitet wird. Also du arbeitest dich von grob nach fein durch in der Mühle. Mit dem Ziel, am Ende alles fein zu haben.
Und diese Zahlen sind aber dann auch abhängig von was für einem Getreide man verarbeitet. Also dieses 405er, das ist jetzt eine Zahl, die bezieht sich jetzt explizit nur auf Weizenmehl. Und bei anderen Mehlen gibt es andere Zahlen, die rinnt.
Die sind wieder auch in der DIN festgelegt. Beim Dinkel geht es zum Beispiel bei 630er los, nicht bei 405er. Das ist zum einen historisch gewachsen, zum anderen auch einfach den Gebäcken geschuldet, den man daraus backen kann als Bäcker oder backen möchte. Es gibt im Roggenbereich, in der DIN, die niedrigste Typ ist glaube ich 997, regional begrenzt, vor allem in Bayern ist es der Fall, gibt es dann auch noch die Typ 610. Die ist nicht in der DIN, aber die wird hergestellt für bestimmte Fastengebäcke. Also die DIN ist das eine, was der Müller dann selbst herstellt, an Typen ist normal das andere. Er ist nur festgelegt, wenn er die Type 550 herstellt, darf er nur in bestimmten Grenzwerten schwanken, was den Mineralstoffgehalt angeht.
Und wie nutzt man jetzt sozusagen diese verschiedenen Mehltypen? Also was das jetzt ist, ist mir klar, also 405, jetzt habe ich den Durchblick, ist so das reine weiße, schalenfreie Kernmittel, das wo alles problemlos ist, keine Ballaststoffe drin, aber kann viel Zucker daraus erzeugt werden. Daraus macht man dann die Brötchen.
Also 405er kannst du gleich wieder vergessen.
Echt?
Fürs Brot und Brötchenbacken, das ist ein, ich nenne es mal Konjutorei-Mehl, also immer wenn du Biskuit machen möchtest oder Plätzchen backen möchtest, Kekse backen möchtest, dann nimmst du das, weil die Backeigenschaften nicht unbedingt über die Typenzahl bestimmt werden, also über den Menagerastoffgehalt, sondern bei Weizen und Dinkel zumindest über den Klebergehalt, über den Glutengehalt und über die Gluteineigenschaften, über die Glutenqualität. Das steht aber nicht auf der Verpackung drauf. Wenn du jetzt einen 405er-Mehl hast, dann hast du da gut und gern viel Klebereiweiß enthalten, aber in einer schlechten Qualität. Was also nicht so gut zum Backen geeignet ist von Brot und Brötchen. Bei Gluten musst du wissen, dass es das Gerüst ist, dein Gerüstbild. Das Gluten, also das Klebereiweiß, hält dir das CO2 der Hefen fest im Teig. Wenn du eine sehr gute Kleberqualität hast und auch noch eine relativ hohe Menge an Gluten, dann kannst du mehr Gas auffangen im Teig, als wenn du schlechte Qualitäten hast und wenig. Das bedeutet, die 405er-Type nehmen wir überhaupt nicht zum Brot und Brötchen backen, sondern erst die Typ 550. Das wäre das klassische Brötchenmehl, weil da zwar relativ wenig Kleber enthalten ist, aber in einer sehr guten Qualität. Und das 1050er-Weizenmehl wäre dann das klassische Brotmehl. Da ist ja auch relativ viel Kleber enthalten. Aber in einer schlechteren Qualität.
Das heißt, das ist auch schon mal entscheidend für ein gutes Brot. Da geht es schon mal los, nicht nur welche Getreidesorte nehme ich überhaupt, sondern vor allem auch in welchem Mischverhältnis, also in welchem Mahlgrad oder Mieltyp schlage ich jetzt hier zu. Das ist so eine ganz strategische Entscheidung.
Genau, also wenn es möglichst locker werden soll, dann nehme ich das zum 50er.
Wenn dieses Gluten so wichtig ist, warum hat das jetzt so einen Hype, dass man das nicht drin haben möchte?
Das hat auch ganz viele verschiedene Gründe. Das eine ist die Psychologie, also dass man einfach Angst davor hat, weil es in aller Munde ist, das Gluten. Das andere sind tatsächlich faktenbasierte Gründe. Der Mensch ist schon immer glutenreiche Nahrung. Weil Weizen ist das Hauptnahrungsmittel in fast allen Kulturen, auch schon über die letzten Jahrtausende gewesen.
Also in Asien nicht so viel.
Ja, in Asien nicht so viel, wobei das auch immer mehr wird in den Gegenden. Aber Weizen ist in aller Regel ein Grundnahrungsmittel gewesen. Und das war auch schon immer glutenhaltig. Sonst wär's kein Weizen. Was dazugekommen ist in den letzten Jahrzehnten, dass Weizen immer glutenreicher geworden ist über die Züchtung und über den Anbau, weil der Landwirt nach Klebergehalt bezahlt wird. Und Klebergehalt heißt beim Bäcker und auch bei Müller, hieß bis vor kurzem, ist gleich Volumenausbeute. Also je höher der Klebergehalt, umso größer das Volumen.
Weil mehr Struktur im Teig ist.
Genau, dass die Rechnung nicht ganz so einfach ist, sondern die Kleberqualität ganz entscheidend ist, wozu ich hier mitzureden hat, ist eigentlich erst in den letzten paar Jahren wirklich ins Bewusstsein getreten und ist auch noch nicht überall im Bewusstsein. Also der Landwirt wird immer noch nach Klebergehalt bezahlt und dann ist er natürlich bestrebt, den Klebergehalt im Getreide möglichst hoch zu ziehen. Also wir sind einfach in einer höheren Dosis an Gluten ausgesetzt in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren. Auch deswegen, weil Gluten nicht nur im Brot steckt, das ist eigentlich das, was wir am wenigsten so vorbereitet, sondern es steckt in ganz vielen Fertigprodukten als Bindemittel. Also wir kommen einfach viel stärker mit mit Gluten in Kontakt, auch wenn wir kein Brot essen.
Verstehe.
Oder keine Nudeln essen oder irgendwas, was in den Teigware ist.
Weil es einfach so als Gerüst auch für andere Lebensmittelprodukte in der industriellen Fertigung verwendet. Wo es aber eigentlich vielleicht nichts zu suchen hat.
Genau. Und dann spielen natürlich die anderen Faktoren eine Rolle. Viele Menschen sind einfach sensibler geworden, weil so viele andere Stoffe noch im Umlauf sind, die den Körper sensibler werden lassen. Da ziehen Immugatoren rein, technische Enzyme, wobei ich das immer mit Vorbehalt sagen muss, das ist überhaupt nicht erforscht, welchen Einfluss solche technischen Enzyme haben, aber sie spielen meiner Meinung nach schon eine Rolle. Also es gibt eine ganze Latte von Zusatzstoffen, die auf natürlichem Wege gar nicht vorkommen würden in unserer Nahrung.
Oder zumindest nicht in der Menge.
Nicht in der Menge und auch nicht in der synthetisierten Form. Und auch das spielt eine Rolle. Also Fakt ist jedenfalls, die Sensitivität auf Weizen hat auf jeden Fall zugenommen, einerseits aufgehangen am Gluten, andererseits aber auch aufgehangen an bestimmten anderen Stoffen, sogenannte Enzymblocker, die in bestimmten Weizensorten stärker zutage treten als in anderen Weizensorten. Und alle, die irgendwie auf Weizen reagieren, haben in aller Regel weniger mit dem Gluten Sorgen als mit diesen Enzymblockern, sogenannte ATI. Was sich kaum verändert hat, ist die Gruppe derjenigen, die tatsächlich glutenallergisch sind, also die Menschen, die Zögearkie haben. Das ist eine vor allem erbbedingte Geschichte und die hat sich in der Menge der Menschen, die daran leiden, kaum verändert.
Das heißt, das gab es schon immer?
Genau.
Das ist aber auch ein relativ kleiner Anteil der Gesellschaft?
Das ist in Deutschland so um die 1%.
Das heißt, das sind eigentlich die Einzigen, die jetzt wirklich auf glutenfreie Ernährung wirklich zwingend Rücksicht nehmen müssen. Und dann gibt es noch die, wie hast du es schon gesagt, die gluten-sensitiven?
Weizensensitiven. Es gibt noch Weizen-Allergiker, die haben dann tatsächlich mit Weizen ein Problem und nicht zwingend mit dem Gluten. Auch das kann man medizinisch ausloten, wer da in die Gruppe reingehört. Und alle anderen, die zwar mit Weizen Sorgen haben, aber die weder Zögerkie haben, noch Weizen allergisch sind, steckt man in die Gruppe der Sensitiven. Ohne genau zu wissen, woran sie leiten.
Irgendwas im Weizen.
Irgendwas haben sie mit dem Weizen zu tun. Die vertragen dann meistens Dinkel ganz gut. Oder Backwaren, die so hergestellt sind, wie ich es für richtig halte. Also mit viel Zeit, mit Sauerteig, wenig Hefe, Ergovielzeit, etc. Also die Weizensensitiven kommen meistens schon relativ gut damit weg, wenn sie Backwaren kaufen oder sich selbst backen, die all das Beherzigen, worüber wir vorhin schon beim Punkt Vollkorn gesprochen haben.
Also Sauerteig oder entsprechende......
lange Quellzeiten, lange Reifezeiten.
Weil jetzt ist es interessant, dass irgendwie Leute, die Weizenprobleme haben, sind bei Dinkel gut aufgehoben. Ich meine, da ist ja auch Gluten drin, aber noch mehr, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Irgendwie enthält mehr Gluten.
Also hier wird sozusagen derzeit in der Diskussion viel dem Gluten zugeschoben, was es vielleicht sozusagen gar nicht verdient hat.
Ja, Gluten ist ein wunderbares Ding. Also kein Gebäck ohne Gluten. Außer Roggen vielleicht.
Aber Roggen ist ja auch Gluten.
Roggen hat auch Gluten in sich, aber es bildet im Roggen kein Gerüst auf wie ein Weizen. Ach, das sind andere Stoffe.
Spielt eine andere Rolle.
Genau. Aber Gluten an sich ist jetzt erst mal nichts Flimmes.
Außer für ein Prozent.
Genau. Es kommt auf die Verarbeitung an und es kommt darauf an, wie weit wir damit traktiert werden und in anderen Nahrungsmitteln.
Verstehe. Also dieser Anti-Gluten-Wahn, den man sich jetzt so in Supermärkten anschauen kann, mit was es jetzt nicht für Millionen Produkte gibt, die irgendwie glutenfrei sind, ist...
Das ist eine Marketinggeschichte. Also es ist meine Meinung. Die, die es wirklich brauchen, das sind die einen Prozent. Für die ist es schön, dass es so ein großes Angebot gibt. Aber das gibt es nur, weil ein Großteil der anderen auch meint, auf Gluten zu reagieren, oder dass es ihnen besser geht ohne Gluten.
Ja, jetzt würde ich ganz gerne mal so ein bisschen auf den Pfad kommen, zu verstehen, was eigentlich ein gutes Brot ausmacht. Und vor allem, was sozusagen in einem Brot denn jetzt tatsächlich drin sein sollte oder zusätzlich noch mit drin sein könnte oder was vielleicht nicht drin sein sollte. Nehmen wir jetzt mal ein beliebiges Standardbrot. Kannst du jetzt ein neues einfallen lassen, was du noch nie gebacken hast? Oder reden wir einfach mal von den typischen Broten, wie man sie jetzt hier findet, um jetzt sozusagen wirklich zum Brot zu kommen. Was nehme ich und wie führe ich das zusammen? Jetzt erstmal so ganz allgemein.
Du brauchst im einfachsten Fall drei Zutaten. Mehl, Wasser und Salz. Wenn du mit Sauerteig arbeitest, reicht das. Dann gibt es nicht mehr als diese drei Zutaten. Wenn du nicht mit Sauerteig arbeitest, brauchst du noch die Hefe dazu. Das wäre dann die vierte Zutat.
Aber Salz ist auch erforderlich?
Salz ist aus verschiedenen Gründen erforderlich. Geschmacklich sowieso. Salzfreies Brot ist zumindest für unsere Kultur schwererträglich. Im Geschmack schmeckt es einfach fad. In Italien gibt es eine Gegend, in der Tuscana, da bäckt man salzfreies Brot. Da ist man es gewöhnt. Ist das aber dann auch mit sehr würzigen Beilagen. Aber für unsere Gefilde geht keiner freiwillig an salzfreies Brot. Das andere ist, dass Salz auch noch baktechnologische Eigenschaften hat. Die Kruste wird erst richtig braun durch Salz, das Volumen wird größer durch Salz. Also das gehört einfach dazu zu nehmen, vernünftigen Brot. Ja, und mehr brauchst du nicht. Dann mischst du das in verschiedensten Wegen zusammen, entweder alles auf einmal oder in verschiedenen Etappen getrennt. Lässt den Teig ruhen, formst das Ganze, lässt ihn nochmal ruhen und wächst. Dann hast du dein Brot. Das klingt erst mal sehr einfach, kann auch sehr einfach sein, kann aber auch sehr komplex werden. Je nachdem, wie du den Teig führst, ob du zum Beispiel im Sauerteig arbeitest oder mit Vor- oder Nullteigen oder ob du den Teig in zwei Stunden durcharbeitest bis zum fertigen Brot oder ob du es über drei Tage ziehst.
Bleiben wir noch mal vielleicht bei dem Klassiker, dem Sauerteig, weil das stand ja nun im Prinzip am Anfang von allem. Wenn ich jetzt ein eigenes Sauerteigbrot erzeugen wollen würde, wie viel Zeit muss ich dann diesem Prozess geben? Und in welcher Reihenfolge muss ich ihn ausführen?
Fangen wir mal mit dem Roggenbrot an, das ist ja unser klassisches Brot in Deutschland. Vorausgesetzt hast du schon eine aktive Sauerteigkultur da und fängst nicht von Null an. Dann brauchst du für mein Standard Roggenbrot ungefähr 24 Stunden.
Und wenn ich bei Null anfange?
Dann rechnest du noch drei, vier Tage drauf.
Okay, fangen wir mal damit an. Fangen wir mal mit nichts an. Also ich habe jetzt Roggenmehl. Welche Mehl-Type wäre jetzt für eigene Equipmente?
Am Anfang, wenn du einen Sauerteig herstellen willst, brauchst du Vollkornmehl. Oder zumindest effektiver, erfolgreicher. Vollkornmehl, weil ja die Tierchen an der Schale hängen. Das Vollkornmehl hat sich die komplette Schale in sich.
Das heißt, dann... was für eine Type wäre das dann?
Gibt es keine Type. Vollkornmehl ist einfach Vollkornmehl.
Das ist dann einfach alles.
Genau. Inklusive Keime. Über den Keime haben wir noch gar nicht geredet. Kann man noch machen.
Das kann man auch so kaufen. Also ich kriege...
Das kannst du kaufen.
Roggen, Vollkornmehl, so einmal alles bitte, aber schön fein gemahlen. Das ist dann auch ziemlich dunkel wahrscheinlich schon. Genau.
Das mischst du... gibt es wieder tausend verschiedene Wege. Der Weg, den ich immer empfehle, ist mit einem Teil Wasser aufs Mehl. Also auf 50 Gramm Mehl, 50 Gramm Wasser. Verrührst du möglichst warmes Wasser um die 40-45 Grad, damit die Teigmasse schon warm ist. Dann lässt du das, wenn du kannst, auch bei 30 Grad ungefähr stehen über einen Tag, 24 Stunden. Und siehst unter Umständen nach diesen 24 Stunden schon irgendwas, eine kleine Blase, oder es riecht vielleicht schon nach was. Das Volumen hat sich vielleicht ein bisschen vergrößert. Wenn nicht, ist auch nicht schlimm. Ist egal, dann mischst du trotzdem wieder 50 Gramm Mehl, 50 Gramm Wasser dazu, zu der Ausgangsmasse, auch wieder warm. Lässt es auch wieder warm stehen über 24 Stunden. Und dann sollte sich schon irgendwas entwickelt haben. Dann haben sich die Milchsäurebakterien, die Hefepilze vermehrt, die Triebleistung steigt, das CO2 wird mehr im Teig, sprich, du hast mehr Volumen. Es riecht schon nach irgendetwas, im besten Fall säuerlich. Und dann geht das Ganze jeden Tag identisch weiter. Du mischst immer wieder 50 Gramm Mehl, 50 Gramm Wasser dazu, lässt es reifen, etc., pp. Und das siehst du über vier, fünf Tage. Lass dann auch irgendwann merken, dass dir das Gebräu in deiner Schüssel oder in deinem Glas früher als nach 24 Stunden einfällt. Das ist immer ein Zeichen, dass es den Punkt der optimalen Reife überschritten hat. Wenn du das siehst, könntest du jetzt sagen, gut, dann warte ich, bis es kurz vorm Einfallen ist, also bis die Wölbung nach oben am Anfang in die Ebene übergeht. Und dann füttere ich schon wieder Mehl nach und Wasser.
Nachmittag heißt es, ich mische alles auch noch mal komplett neu durch.
Und zwar an dem Punkt, wo die höchste Aktivität zu sehen ist. Also wenn das meiste Gas im Teig ist, bevor das Teiggerüst wieder gesprengt wird durch das Gas. Oder du sagst, du wirst deine 24-Stunden-Taktik beibehalten, dann müsstest du aber nicht mehr der gesamten Vortagesmasse dieses bisschen Mehl und Wasser geben. Die Relation wird immer kleiner. Du hast jeden Tag mehr Sauerteig im Glas und gibst trotzdem die gleiche Menge Mehl und Wasser zu. Du hast also effektiv gesehen, auf eine bestimmte Menge an Sauerteig immer weniger Nahrung. Deshalb reift das auch immer schneller und fällt schneller ein. Du kannst es also sagen, du gibst nicht mehr deinen zum Beispiel 300 Gramm vom Vortag diese 50 Gramm Mehl und Wasser, sondern gibst nur noch 50 Gramm vom Vortag deine 50 Gramm Mehl und Wasser. Dann hast du ein ausgewogeneres Verhältnis zwischen der Nahrung und denen, die es essen. In den Kursen sage ich immer, stellt euch vor, da sitzen 15 Leute. Stellt euch vor, ich gebe euch für eine Woche lang nur ein Brot für alle 15 Leute, die da sitzen im Vergleich zu der Taktik, dass ich jedem ein Brot gebe für eine Woche. So ungefähr ist das in dem Glas. Wenn ich 300 Gramm Ausgangsmasse mit 50 Gramm Mehl in Wasser füttere, dann reicht das. Du kannst auch mehr Mehl und mehr Wasser füttern, dann hast du aber einen süßen Preieffekt. Am Ende dieser vier, fünf Tage hast du eine Riesenschüssel mit Mehl und Wasser, also mit Sauerteig, die du nicht wirklich brauchst am Ende.
Ach so, also nur weil ich jetzt dann mehr produziere, als ich brauche?
Genau.
Aber da wäre jetzt nichts falsch dran?
Die Relation ist wichtig, es ist genügend Nahrung für eine gewisse Zeit vorhanden. Ob du jetzt mehr Mehl und Wasser zur Ausgangsmasse zugibst oder ob du die Ausgangsmasse begrenzt, ist egal.
Aber um jetzt so ein Kilo Brot zu erzeugen, musst du ja im Prinzip auch ein Kilo Mehl reinschmeißen?
Nein, nein, nein. Für ein Kilo Brot brauchst du, je nach Rezept, vielleicht 600 Gramm Mehl, 500 Gramm Mehl manchmal. Aber da sind wir ja noch lange nicht. Wir sind jetzt erst mal dabei, den Sauerteig herzustellen.
Ja.
Das haben wir jetzt vielleicht drei, vier Tage getan, dieses Prozedere. Wir sehen, das blubbert vor sich hin, riecht säuerlich, ist alles in Ordnung. Dann können wir sagen, brechen wir das Ganze ab und ich nehme mir jetzt ein Schraubglas her. Ich habe zu Hause so ein 400-Milliliter-Glas, da passen um die 100 Gramm Sauerteig rein, wenn er reif ist, also aufgegangen ist. Und diese 100 Gramm nehme ich mir ab von dem großen Gebräu, was ich mir jetzt über die letzten Tage gezogen habe. Also wenn du sagst, du mischst immer noch mehr Mehl und Wasser dazu, dann hast du vielleicht zwei Kilo davon. Nach diesen vier, fünf Tagen. Du nimmst davon 100 Gramm ab in dein Schraubglas und dieses Schraubglas stellst du in den Kühlschrank. Und das ist ab sofort deine Sauerteigkultur, von der du, je nachdem wie lange du wächst, dein Leben lang im Zweifel zählen kannst.
Ein Leben lang?
Ein Leben lang.
Wird das nicht irgendwann schlicht?
Du musst es pflegen. Die anderen 1900 Gramm, die ist noch übrig, sind von den zwei Kilo. Die könntest du, wenn sie gerade pünktlich reif sind, für einen Brotteig nutzen. Also noch mal Mehl dazugeben, Salz dazugeben, dann auch und Wasser in bestimmten Relationen und daraus ein Brot backen. Wenn das ganze System schon eingefallen ist, also überreift, dann kannst du da zwar ein Brot rausbacken, das wird aber nicht mehr ordentlich schmecken. Das heißt, im schlimmsten Falle kommt das Zeug auf den Kompost. Deshalb ist das Ziel schon in dieser ersten Prozesse über die paar Tage, möglichst wenig Sauerteig zu produzieren, weil du den Großteil sowieso weg tun musst oder verschenken musst. Die Geschichte ist gegessen. Die Geburt haben wir hinter uns. Jetzt haben wir ein Schraubglas Sauerteig im Kühlschrank stehen. Dieses Schraubglas heißt, oder das, was da drin ist, heißt dann nicht mehr Sauerteig, sondern Anstellgut oder Starter. Es ist immer noch ein Sauerteig, aber er heißt anders, weil du aus diesem Glas eine bestimmte Menge rausnehmen kannst, um damit einen Sauerteig herzustellen. Und dann, nach Rezept, nehmen wir wieder das Roggenbrot, der steht dann im Rezept. Bei Stichpunkt Sauerteig, du nimmst zum Beispiel 500 Gramm Roggenmehl, 500 Gramm Wasser und 50 Gramm Anstellgut. Diese 50 Gramm holst du dir aus dem Glas im Kühlschrank. Und misch das jetzt mit dem Rest zusammen, so wie es dann im Rezept aussteht. Dann lässt du es reifen, das sind meistens zwischen 12 und 20 Stunden. Und dann hast du einen vollreifen Sauerteig, den du dann für den eigentlichen Brotteig noch mit Mehl und Wasser und Salz vermischt gehen lässt und so weiter. Dieses Anstellgut spart dir beim Backen immer diese vier, fünf Tage Geburt. Wenn du das nicht wegnimmst, sondern mit dem vier, fünf Tage alten, hergeführten Sauerteig gleich dein Brot bäckst und gar nichts wegnimmst, dann musst du beim nächsten Backtag wieder vier, fünf Tage investieren.
Aber nur, wenn ich jetzt die 50 Gramm Anstellgut hinzumache, ist das ja auch nicht sofort nach dem Verrühren ein vollwertiger Teig, sondern das muss ich ja...
Der muss auch mal aufgehen. Aber dann halt nur zwölf bis zwanzig Stunden und keine vier, fünf Tage.
Okay, also dann, wenn ich also einmal mir so meinen Kernsauerteig, mein Anstellgut erzeugt habe, kann ich im Prinzip immerhin, immer binnen eines Tages wieder eine nicht beliebige, aber größere Menge Teig in derselben Qualität herstellen.
Genau, das ist ja der große Vorteil. Diese vier, fünf Tage machst du einmal in deinem Leben, im besten Falle, und dann zehrst du immer von dem kleinen Schraubglas im Kühlschrank.
Warum wird denn das nicht schlecht?
Das wird schlecht, definitiv wird das schlecht, wenn du das Ganze nicht pflegst. Du kannst dir innerhalb einer gewissen Zeit was da rausnehmen und damit ein Sauerteig nach Rezept ansetzen, aber die Tierchen arbeiten ja weiter in dem Glas. Die bauen ja weiter das Mehl ab und dann produzieren CO2 und Sorge. Und irgendwann bist du an dem Punkt angekommen, wo die Nahrung fehlt für die Mikroorganismen im Glas. Das heißt, du musst wieder was zuführen. Das ist eigentlich die gleiche Idee, die du auch schon in den vier, fünf Tagen am Anfang gemacht hast. Du gibst immer Mehl und Wasser zu. Du musst es jetzt nicht täglich tun, sondern es reicht zum Beispiel alle sieben Tage, also einmal die Woche. Bauen das Mehl also langsam mal ab. Meine Prozedur ist immer alle sieben Tage relativ routiniert. Nehme ich mir das Gläschen raus, nehme ein neues Glas daneben, packe in das neue Glas wieder 50 Gramm Mehl und 50 Gramm Wasser. Muss jetzt kein Vollkohlenmehl mehr sein, weil wir die Tierchen ja schon eingefangen haben und vermehrt haben. Und nehme mir dann aus dem alten Glas, aus dem sieben Tage alten Glas ein Teelöffel Anstellgut raus und packe das in das neue Glas, verrühre das und lasse das wieder, wenn es geht, warm aufreifen.
Für einen weiteren Tag?
Für, wenn ich es auch noch warmstehen lasse, vielleicht acht Stunden, ab bis zehn Stunden über Nacht. Und wenn ich dann sehe, dass es leicht gewirbt und vielleicht schon ein bisschen in die Ebene zurückfällt, dann stelle ich es wieder in den Kühlschrank. Wie so ein Tamagotchi. Es muss immer gepflegt werden, wie ein Haustier.
Ja, und es ist vor allem so kontrollierte Entwicklung. Man macht das einmal so richtig schön lebendig, dass es alles enthält, und dann wird es so quasi in so eine Zeitlupe befördert, dadurch, dass es im Kühlschrank gepackt wird. Und nach einer Woche wäre trotz dieser Zeitlupe der Prozess dann irgendwann so weit, dass es sich quasi selber auffrisst, und dann setze ich ein neues Glas an, ernähre das mit dem Urschleim aus dem anderen Glas, mache dann so einen Schnelldurchlauf quasi, weil das einfach schon so konzentriert ist in diesem Sauerteig, sodass das wieder etwas Gleichwertiges erzeugt, und dann wieder Zeitlupe.
Genau. Das Ziel ist immer, die Fische am Leben zu erhalten in dem Glas, sodass du innerhalb dieser sieben Tage dir mal was rausnehmen kannst und damit einen Sauerteig einsetzen kannst.
Das heißt, du musst eigentlich spätestens alle sieben Tage aktiv werden.
Ja.
Aber man muss nicht unbedingt ein Brot machen.
Man muss nur diesen kleinen Prozess machen. Aber diese Auffrischung nennt sich das. Auffrischung führst du durch, egal ob du beckst, wann du beckst, wie du beckst und was du beckst, ganz stur, gerne alle sieben Tage einmal auffrischen. Die Sieben-Tage-Regel ist einfach nur für den eigenen Kopf da. Ob der jetzt nach acht Tagen aufgefrischt wird oder nach fünf, spielt zwar schon eine Rolle, aber keine so große Rolle für den Brot.
Aber zwei Wochen sollte man nicht warten.
Also ein Roggensauerteig hält gut und gern auch mal zwei Wochen durch. Wenn wir jetzt zum Thema Weizensauerteig kommen, sieht die Welt ganz anders aus. Weizensauerteige bauen schneller ab. Die haben dann auch schneller eine Flüssigkeit oben auf der Oberfläche abgeschieden. Das ist ein Gemisch aus Alkohol, Wasser und Säure, nennt sich Fusel. Sieht grau aus und je länger das Gläschen mit dem alten Sauerteig im Kühlschrank steht, umso größer wird die Schicht. Das sind einfach die Abbauprodukte der Mikroorganismen.
Ist das der Name Fusel her, den man ja sonst eigentlich so für schlechte Alkohol benutzt?
Das ist eher andersrum. Wenn du da rein riechst, riechst du einfach schrecklich nach Aceton und anderen Sachen. Das hebe wahrscheinlich den Namen Fusel für das Gebräu da oben drauf. Was ich sagen will, spätestens wenn du diese Flüssigkeit siehst, solltest du aufrutschen. Egal ob das sieben Tage sind oder fünf Tage. Kommt ja auf die Kühlschranktemperatur an. Wenn er bei mir bei 5 Grad steht, baut er langsamer, aber was, wenn er bei dir bei 8 Grad im Kühlschrank steht.
Und woran sieht man dem Roggensauer-Teig an, dass er drüber ist?
Das Gleiche. Der kriegt auch die Flüssigkeit nur deutlich langsamer später als Walzen. Nur damit du für dich irgendeine Routine hast, sage ich immer alle sieben Tage. Dann hast du meinetwegen, was weiß ich, Freitag nach der Arbeit oder Sonntag vor der Tagesshow deine Routine, nimmst ein neues Glas etc., mischt das alles zusammen, dauert vielleicht fünf Minuten und du bist durch. Du hast wieder für eine Woche Ruhe. Die traditionelle Variante, seinen Sauerteig zu pflegen, ist ein bisschen anders gewesen. Man hat ja früher auf den Dörfern und auch in Bäckereien nicht so viel verschiedenes gebacken, wie wir es jetzt privat tun im Haushalt oder auch wie es in den Bäckereien passiert. Man hat meistens nur ein Rezept gehabt, ein Roggenbrot. Zum Beispiel einfach das Brot. Genau, das Brot. Man hat den Sauerteig angesetzt mit einem bisschen Sauerteig ansteigut, was man sich aufgehoben hatte vom letzten Backtag. Und hat dann von dem reifen Sauerteig die Menge, die man vorher zum Ansetzen dazugegeben hat, wieder abgenommen. Also ganz plastisch, wenn ich ein Kilo Mehl verarbeite und ein Kilo Wasser und 100 Gramm Ansteigut am Abend zusammenrühre und dann über Nacht reifen lasse, dann nehme ich am Morgen, wenn der Sauerteig reif ist, die 100 Gramm Ansteigut, die ich dazugegeben habe, wieder ab. Packt die wieder irgendwo ins Kalte in den Keller und am nächsten Backtag nehme ich diese 100 Gramm wieder raus und setze damit mit Mehl und Wasser wieder den nächsten Sauerteig an. Funktioniert wunderbar, wenn ich nicht vergesse, dieses Ansteigut abzunehmen. Wenn ich es nämlich vergesse, habe ich keins mehr. Dann muss ich diese 4-5-Tages-Prozedur wieder durchziehen. Und der andere Nachteil ist, an diesem traditionellen Verfahren, dass ich, wenn ich konstante Ergebnisse haben möchte, immer nur das gleiche Rezept verbacken kann. Sobald ich ein anderes Rezept verbacke, was eine andere Sauerteigzusammensetzung hat, also zum Beispiel mit weniger Wasser zusammengerührt ist oder eventuell Salz ins Sauerteig schon steckt oder ich eine andere Mehl-Type nehme, andere Roggenmehl-Type, verändere ich gleich das Gleichgewicht im Sauerteig und habe so dann jedes Mal eine andere Qualität meines Anstellgutes. Ist immer anders zusammengesetzt. Wenn ich ungefähr abschätzen möchte, wie mein Anstellgut arbeitet, welche Qualität es hat, welche Triebeleistung, dann sollte ich bestrebt sein, immer unter gleichen Bedingungen aufzufrischen. Also immer die gleiche Mehl-Type zu nehmen, die gleiche Wassermenge, wenn es geht, die gleichen Temperaturen, um das Gleichgewicht konstant zu halten in dem Gebräu aus verschiedensten Mikroorganismen. Sobald ich an einer Stellschraube drehe und die Temperatur ist eine ganz wichtige Stellschraube, auch die Wassermenge, verändere ich das Gleichgewicht und habe dann plötzlich eine andere Anstellgut-Qualität als in der Woche vorher.
Einmal muss sich ja das Gleichgewicht ändern, nämlich, wir haben ja gesagt, mit Vollkornmehl fangen wir an, damit da eben auch die entsprechenden Hieven und Milchsäurebakterien und so weiter am Start sind. Danach, das Auffrischen, mache ich dann schon mit feiner gemahlenem Mehl. Welches Mehl würde ich jetzt für meinen MyFast-Sauerteig dann sozusagen hinzufügen?
Das kommt darauf an, womit du am häufigsten backen willst. Du kannst auch sagen, ich füttere weiter mit Vollkornmehl. Geht auch, wenn du Vollkornbrote backen möchtest. Wenn du sagst, du backst lieber helle Roggenbrote in der nächsten Zeit, dann nimmst du die Hauptmehltypik, die du dafür brauchst. Also meinetwegen 1150er Roggen oder 1370er Roggen. Das spielt dann nicht die Rolle. Viel wichtiger ist, dass du dabei bleibst, dass du immer die konstante Bedingung schaffst.
Okay, das glaube ich, habe ich verstanden. Also man kann sich einfach quasi so eine Sauerteigbasis selber schaffen, über ein paar Tage hinweg. Und noch einfacher kann man sie sich dann im Prinzip über einen beliebig langen Zeitraum einfach erhalten. Im Prinzip so eine Tätigkeit wie das Feuer am Laufen halten damals. Man muss halt immer mal wieder was nachlegen und immer dafür sorgen, dass so das Minimum an Flamme so vor sich hin brät. Aber es braucht halt auch immer wieder Nahrung, aber eben auch nicht zu viel, weil es soll ja nur halten, dass wenn man mal ein größeres Feuer machen will, dass man dann eben etwas hat, womit man das Ganze zünden lassen kann.
Genau, das ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel. Was du da tust, über die sieben Tage, ist tatsächlich nur die Flamme am Glimmen zu halten, die Glut irgendwie nicht ausgehen zu lassen. Wenn du jetzt vorhast, ein gutes Sauerteigbrot zu backen, insbesondere wenn du von morgen weggehst, Richtung Weizen oder Dinkel, dann braucht es ein bisschen mehr Aufwand, um das große Feuer wieder zu entzünden. Kannst du dir vorstellen, wenn du ein Sauerteig ansetzt mit einem Anstellgut, was du gerade eben erst im Kühlschrank gestellt hast, also was sehr fit ist, ein Tag alt vielleicht, dann wird dein Sauerteig auch fitter, aktiver, treibstärker, milder, als wenn du den Sauerteig mit einem Anstellgut ansetzt, was sieben Tage alt ist, was ja eigentlich schon relativ inaktiv ist. Wenn du also vorhast, ein möglichst gutes Sauerteigbrot zu backen, dann nimm entweder das frisch aufgefrischte Anstellgut, also nicht nach sieben Tagen, sondern nach ein, zwei, drei Tagen, oder frische einfach nochmal auf, außerhalb der sieben Tages Routine. Wenn du also morgen Abend deinen Sauerteig ansetzen willst für dein Weizenbrot, dann bringst du ihn schon ein bisschen auf Trab, dass er weiß, was er zu tun hat.
Ohne, dass man jetzt ein neues Glas produziert, im selben Glas quasi.
Nee, schon immer neues Glas. Das ist auch noch eine Geschichte. Theoretisch könntest du das Mehl und das Wasser auch in das alte Glas reinkippen und verrühren, dann hast du aber in aller Regel sehr, sehr viel Restanstellgut in dem Glas. Also von den 100 Gramm meinetwegen noch 50 Gramm über, die du nicht verbraucht hast in der Woche. Dann hast du wieder die Geschichte mit einem Brot für 15 Leute. Also wenig Nahrung für viele Mikroorganismen. Deshalb nimmst du lieber ein neues Glas, gibst da viel Nahrung rein und wenig Mikroorganismen. Das für die wenigen, die da drin sind, möglichst viele Nahrung.
Die sich ordentlich anfressen können. Das wird dann zu der hohen Aktivität und hoher Aktivität heißt, guter Teig für gutes Brot. Okay, vielleicht lassen wir die Hefeteige erstmal noch so ein bisschen aus dem Blick heraus. Jetzt will ich das Brot auch auf den Weg bringen. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie meinen Anstellgut. Das habe ich jetzt gegebenenfalls auch nochmal frisch aktiviert. Das pulsiert geradezu vor Erwartungen. Und jetzt mache ich irgendwie meinen neuen Teig. Also neues Mehl, dasselben Typ, mit dem ich auch mein Anstellgut erzeugt habe. Wasser natürlich, dann auch wieder warm.
Wenn es um Sauerteige geht, aber immer warm.
Immer warm.
Wenn wir ein mildes Brot haben wollen, wenn es nicht dominant sauer schmecken soll. Und warm heißt bei Roggenbroten ungefähr eine Teigtemperatur von 30 Grad. Bei Weizen um die 28 Grad. Aber so in der Träge, um die 30 Grad, dreht sich alles, wenn es um Sauerteigebrote geht. Und das kriegen wir hin über die Wassertemperatur.
30, 40 Grad hast du gesagt.
Ja, kommt nur auf die anderen Komponenten an, die im Rezept stehen. Aber so um die 40, 45 Grad sind meistens auch im Spielen. Was dann aber schon wieder fast tödlich ist, für den Sauerteig. Alles oberhalb von ungefähr 40 Grad führt zum Ableben der Mikroorganismen. Deshalb musst du aufpassen, wenn da im Rezept tatsächlich steht, du willst 50 Grad heißes Wasser nehmen, gibst du das Ganze nicht direkt auf den Sauerteig, sondern nimmst das Mehl als Brennschicht. Also Wasser unten in die Schüssel und dann Mehl oben drauf und Sauerteig noch ein Stück weiter oben drauf. Dann ist der abgekoppelt von dem heißen Wasser. Beim Verrühren vergleicht sich das relativ schnell an die Temperatur.
Also wenn man jetzt das Anstellgut direkt ins heiße Wasser tun würde, würden die dann alle schreien. Okay. Mehl drüber und dann verrühren, dann gleicht sich das alles wieder aus und dann nochmal einen Tag stehen lassen.
Du bist jetzt beim Sauerteig oder beim Brotteig?
Jetzt will ich Brotteig machen. Sauerteig haben wir ja erzeugt, gepflegt und seit mehreren Jahren schon durch den Kühlschrank gebracht. Jetzt soll es auch mal zum Brot kommen.
Im Kühlschrank steht das Anstellgut. Das ist eigentlich auch ein Sauerteig, aber um es gedanklich zu trennen vom Sauerteig, der fürs Brot relevant ist, heißt es Anstellgut. Mit dem Anstellgut setzt du dir erst mal den Brot-Sauerteig an. Fütterst einfach Mehl und Wasser dazu. Das steht dann aber schon im jeweiligen Rezept, was du da tun sollst mit dem Anstellgut. Lässt den dann reifen, zum Beispiel 12 Stunden, vom Rezept abhängig. Hast dann einen vollreifen Sauerteig, der hat sich also gewölbt und dann schon wieder ein bisschen nach unten bewegt, irgendwo in die Ebene, was ich vorhin schon mal erzählt habe. Der kriegt schon ein bisschen Hunger. Genau, der ist vollreif. Der sollte dann auch mehr oder weniger auf dem Punkt verarbeitet werden. Wenn der schon wieder eingefallen ist, hat er nicht mehr die Eigenschaften, die er haben soll, wird also schon saurer und hat nicht mehr die Triebleistung.
Weil die alle schon so ein bisschen abgehauen haben.
Genau. Nehmen wir an, der ist vollreif. Dann steht im Rezept unter Stichpunkt Hauptteig der gesamte Sauerteig. Dann steht da was von irgendeinem Mehl und noch einem Mehl vielleicht, Salz und Wasser. Das rührst du alles zusammen. Wenn es ein Roggenbrot ist, reicht es tatsächlich, das zusammenrühren. Das muss nicht wirklich geknetet werden. Nur, dass alles eine homogene Masse ist. Dann hast du deinen Brotteig fertig. Der hat dann, wenn es ein Roggensauerteigbrot wird, idealerweise 30 Grad Teigtemperatur. Und steht dann erstmal vor sich hin, das nennt man erste Teigruhe oder Stockgare, um die Prozesse, die das Wasser in Gang bringt mit dem Mehl, zu beschleunigen, in Gang zu setzen. Also Enzyme in Gang zu setzen, die bestimmte Sachen abbauen im Mehl, die Hefen, die im Sauerteig stecken, zu aktivieren, die Milchsäurebakterien in Gang zu setzen. Etc. Also die erste Teigruhe ist dazu da, das ganze System in Gang zu bringen. Und wenn das System in Gang gebracht ist, also das vielleicht sogar schon ein bisschen aufgegangen ist, der Teig an sich, dann gehst du hin und formst das Ganze. Der Bäcker sagt dazu Wirken, also Rundwirken oder Langwirken, je nachdem, wie das Brot aussehen soll am Ende. Und dann geht das Brot noch einmal auf, also der Teig geht noch einmal auf. Meistens, wenn es ein Brot tatsächlich werden soll, in einem Gärkorb, in einer Form, einer Schale, um die Form zu halten. Und nach einer bestimmten Reifezeit wird das Ding dann aus dem Korb gekippt und gebacken. Vorher vielleicht noch eingeschnitten, kommt darauf an, was man erreichen möchte. Und das ist der kritische Punkt. An dem Punkt scheitern die meisten Hobbybäcker. Wann gebe ich den Teig in den Ofen? In welchem reifen Zustand? Wie muss ich das Gebilde anfühlen? Wie muss es aussehen? Wie stark muss es aufgegangen sein, um in den Ofen zu gehen? Die meisten machen den Fehler, dass sie es zu lange im Korb gehen lassen. Das sieht dann wunderschön aus, wunderbar aufgegangen. Hat sich verdoppelt ungefähr im Volumen.
Ja, so ein bisschen der klassische Wertmaßstab. Guck mal, wie toll groß das jetzt geworden ist.
Genau, und dann kippt derjenige das raus in den Ofen, auf den Backstein und sieht, wie wunderbar das Ganze einfällt.
Das System. Weil es im Prinzip seine Energie schon verbraucht hat und dann in der Lage ist, der Hitze zu widerstehen.
Das sind verschiedene Dinge. Das erste ist der Teigabbau. Schreitet natürlich voran, je länger das da im Korb liegt. Also das Gerüst wird geschwächt. Und das zweite ist, dass das Gas ja immer mehr wird und entsprechend gegen das Gerüst drückt und irgendwann sprengt das einfach das Gerüst auseinander. Und das System fällt ein. Und durch den Aufprall, den du beim Rauskippen erzeugst, fällt es etwas früher ein, als es das eh getan hätte. Und wenn du es dann noch versuchst, einzuschneiden, ist sowieso alles vorbei, dann fällt es definitiv ein. Es hat dann den Zustand der Überreife, der Übergare. Das wollen wir eigentlich nie erreichen. Das Brot soll im Idealfall den Zustand der knappen Gare haben. Das heißt, es geht im Korb ein bisschen auf und den Großteil des Volumens entwickelt es aber erst beim Backen im Ofen. Also wenn das Ding in den Ofen geht, muss es noch sehr stabil sein. Auch wenn du den Korb aufschlägst auf den Tisch, dann fällt da nichts ein. Du siehst, es hat sich was bewegt, ist ein bisschen aufgegangen, aber noch sehr, sehr stabil. Und wenn du mit dem Finger heran drückst, dann merkst du auch irgendwie, dass es noch...
Homogen.
Da gibt es noch einen Gegendruck, wenn du reindrückst, da ist noch Widerstand da. Und das ist ein gutes Zeichen, um das noch gut einzuschneiden, ohne dass es einfällt.
Das Einschneiden hat jetzt nur so kosmetische Gründe?
Nee, in dem Fall schon. In dem Fall hat es auch andere Gründe. Wenn du es mit knapper Gare in den Ofen schieben willst, da also noch sehr viel Volumenzuwachs zu erwarten ist im Ofen, musst du dem Volumenzuwachs einen Weg geben, sich auszubreiten. Wenn du es einfach so in den Ofen schiebst, mit einer glatten Teigoberfläche, dann wird das Volumen sehr klein bleiben, weil die Oberfläche verhautet, verkrustet durch die Hitze. Dann kann es sich aus den Negasen irgendwohin.
Durch den Schnitt schafft man quasi Möglichkeiten der Expansion.
Genau. Und wenn du es nicht einschneidest, kann entweder gar nichts passieren, das hebt sich nicht, bleibt also so klein und fest, kompakt wie es war im Ofen, oder es sucht sich einen anderen Weg. Und der andere Weg ist dann meistens da, wo sich Ober- und Unterhitze treffen, an der kältesten Stelle, also am Brotboden, links um den Brotboden herum, entwickelt sich dann so ein Atompilz. Das sind auch ganz klassische Anfängerbrote. Und wenn du bei mir einen Block auf die ersten Seiten zurückblätterst, sehen die genauso aus.
Du hast sozusagen deine komplette Historie von Fehlannahmen auch durchdokumentiert.
Komplett unverändert seit 2009.
Ich meine, aus Fehlern lernt man mehr als alles andere. Von daher ist das glaube ich auch ganz sinnvoll. So ein bisschen auch wie der erste Podcast, der ist ja auch komplett meistens in sich zusammengefallen. Und den muss man aber trotzdem online lassen, wenn er dich nicht mehr hören möchte. Okay, also ich fasse noch mal kurz zusammen. Man macht sich also mal seinen Teig, lässt ihn ungefähr zwölf Stunden ziehen, damit er überhaupt erst mal so richtig durchwürgt ist. Der Sauerteig. Genau. Und dann, das Timing muss ich sagen, habe ich danach nicht so ganz verstanden.
Das habe ich auch nicht erzählt.
Ja genau, also hast du nur angedeutet, dass es da Zeiträume gibt, aber nicht genau wie die dann sind. Soll ich das noch mal zusammenfassen?
Das ist jetzt sehr variabel. Das hängt von unzähligen Faktoren ab. Wie lang ist jetzt die erste Teigrohe, wie lang die zweite Teigrohe. Kommt auch darauf an, wie soll das Brot von innen aussehen, soll es feinporig sein, soll es grobporig sein, sollen die Blasen im Inneren des Brotes gleichmäßig verteilt sein oder unregelmäßig. Da gibt es ganz viele Einflussfaktoren. Was immer relativ konstant ist, ist die Summe aus der ersten Teigrohe und der zweiten Teigrohe. Das beschreibt sozusagen die Toleranz, die der Teig hat, das Gas aufzufangen, dieser Zeitraum. Und du entscheidest dann als Bäcker, gebe ich dem Teig in der ersten Teigrohe mehr Zeit oder gebe ich ihm in der zweiten Teigrohe mehr Zeit? Und diese Wahl hat dann einen Einfluss auf das Innenleben des Brotes, unter anderem auf das Innenleben.
Aber was leitet denn diese Ruhe jetzt ein? Ich meine, ich lasse das Ding ja erst mal zwölf Stunden vor sich hin.
Da sind wir ja noch beim Sauerteig. Die erste Teigrohe und die zweite. Ich glaube, der erste Teig beginnt beim eigentlichen Brotteig.
Ja, das meinte ich ja auch. Okay, vielleicht haben wir uns missverstanden, ich fasse nochmal zusammen. Also ich hab ja mein Anstellgut, das nehme ich hin, jetzt will ich ja einen neuen, jetzt will ich den Teig für mein Brot machen.
Mit dem Anstellgut machst du ja erst den Sauerteig. Das ist eine Vorarbeit vor dem eigentlichen Brotteig.
Ah, verstehe. Das sind die 12 Stunden und das mische ich dann sozusagen noch mal mit meinem Mehl, aber da warte ich dann nicht so mega lange.
Kannst du gern tun, aber musst du nicht.
Okay, bringt nichts.
Kommt darauf an, was du erreichen möchtest. Okay. Also du kannst die erste Teigruhe, die Stockgare und die zweite Teigruhe, die Stückgare im Prinzip beliebig lang halten. Je länger du sie hältst, umso weniger Triebmittel kommt zum Einsatz. Also umso weniger Sauerteig. Oder bei der Hefe umso weniger Hefe. Du kannst also tatsächlich auch so einen Teig, den du da zusammen gebraut hast, auch mit Sauerteig unter Umständen zusammen gewurfelt hast, kannst du durchaus über 24 Stunden, 72 Stunden ruhen lassen. Dann entsprechend kalt oder kälter, als wenn du es in drei Stunden durchziehst. Und je länger du ihn reifen lässt, umso aromatischer, komplexer werden die Brote.
Einfach, weil der reiche Enzümer und andere Wirkstoffe da mehr Treiben entfalten können.
Mehr Anbauprozesse.
Aber schlecht wird es nicht?
Schlecht wird es nicht. Wenn du es jetzt zwei Wochen im Kühlschrank lässt, dann ist der Teig auch abgebaut irgendwann. Dann wird er auch irgendwann anfangen zu schimmeln. Das wäre dann übertrieben, aber so in einem Rahmen von drei Stunden bis drei Tagen ist das ein Problem.
Aber in dem Moment ist der Teig gekühlt.
In aller Regel. Es gibt auch Taktiken, das bei Raumtemperatur zu tun, dann mit extrem wenig Triebmittel, also extrem wenig Hefe oder Sauerteig. Wenn du einen Hefeteig über 24 Stunden führen willst, bei Raumtemperatur, dann brauchst du im Schnitt so um die 0,5 Gramm Hefe, also ein halbes Gramm Hefe.
Was viel ist oder wenig ist?
Das ist extrem wenig. Davon brauchst du ein Achtzigstel.
Okay, also man nimmt wenig, weil sonst wird es einfach explodieren.
Genau, dann geht es einfach zu schnell. Dann ist er zu schnell überreif oder überhaupt zu schnell reif und du hast weniger Geschmack. Du kannst mehr Hefe nehmen, wenn du das ganze Ding kalt stellst in den Kühlschrank. Dann nimmst du ungefähr die 10-fache Menge an Hefe über den gleichen Zeitraum.
Und dann rein in den Ofen und dann kommt was super bei raus. Jetzt haben wir Hefe und Sauerteig wieder so ein bisschen zusammengeworfen.
Aber das Prozedere ist das gleiche. Das Prozedere ist das gleiche. Also sobald du den Brotteig machst, hast du vom Ablauf her die gleichen Schlafen.
Okay, also es ist eigentlich egal, ob ich jetzt sage, ich mach's mit Hefe oder ich mach's mit meinem Sauerteig. Ab da ist Backen einfach Backen. Was sind denn so, wie frag ich denn das jetzt, also es gibt ja so Brotarten, also ich meine, wenn man heute so so Bäcker geht, oh weia, ich meine, da glaube ich ja mittlerweile schon gar nichts mehr. Ich meine, die ganzen Bezeichnungen für irgendwelche Brote sind ja mehr schon mehr so Brandnames und irgendwelche Erfindungen, die wahrscheinlich vor zwei Jahren noch keiner kannte, oder? Das täusche ich mich. Das ist es.
Das ist einfach Quatsch. Es muss immer irgendwo die Verkehrsbezeichnung dabei stehen im Kleingedruckten. Die ist dann definiert. Also du kannst, was machen wir, keine Ahnung, Berliner irgendwas Brot kann dranstehen und unten drunter muss dann aber stehen zum Beispiel Roggenmischbrot. Also die eigentlichen Brotsorten sind relativ eng begrenzt, die es gibt.
Darauf wollte ich nämlich hinaus. Also was für Brotsorten trifft man denn jetzt eigentlich üblicherweise so an? Was muss man eigentlich wirklich unterscheiden?
In Deutschland gibt es Roggenbrot, Roggenmischbrot, Weizenmischbrot, Weizenbrot und das gleiche nochmal mit Dinkel. Und dann kann der Bäcker noch ein paar Körner und Saaten reinmischen oder sich ein paar Teigführungen ausdenken, die dann am Geschmack was ändern. Aber im Grunde, die reinen Sorten, was ich unter Sorte verstehe, ist entweder ein 100%er aus jeweils einer bestimmten Getreideart oder eine Mischung aus verschiedenen. Und dann gibt es halt rechtliche Vorgaben, wie muss es genannt werden.
Und Roggenmischbrot heißt, der Hauptbestandteil ist Roggen, aber es sind noch andere Sachen drin.
Genau, es müssen mindestens 50% Roggen enthalten sein, also mehr, mehr als 50% Roggen und bis zu 90% Roggen. Wenn mehr als 90% Roggen dran sind, dann hast du ein Roggenbrot. Da sind die Grenzen. Also zwischen 50 und 90% Roggenanteil hast du ein Roggenmischbrot.
Aber ob jetzt Hefe oder Sauerteig zum Einsatz kam, um dieses Brot zu machen, sagt das ja nicht aus.
Das sagt es nicht aus, nein.
Und ist das relevant?
Ja, für dich als Käufer vielleicht. Wenn du ein Roggenmischbrot kaufst, dann ist aus backtechnologischen Gründen wiederum in aller Regel ein Sauerteig verarbeitet oder ein Teigseuerungsmittel, also auf jeden Fall Säure. Wenn du ein Weizenbrot kaufst, ist in aller Regel zumindest bei uns in den deutschsprachigen Gebieten kein Sauerteig im Spiel, sondern Hefe. Du kannst auch ein Weizenbrot 100 Prozent aus Sauerteig backen, ohne Backhefe, aber das ist bei uns einfach nicht üblich.
Aber im Prinzip wäre das ja auch noch eine relevante Information, oder?
Ja, also die meisten Bäcker werben auch damit, sobald die mit Sauerteig arbeiten und dann auch noch mit sogenannten Natursauerteig. Steht das irgendwo, dann ist es eine Werbestrategie.
Also man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen, wenn es nicht dransteht, ist es Hefe. Außer beim Roggenbesprud, wo es...
Genau, sobald du irgendwo was mit Roggen siehst, als Hauptkomponente ist es ein allereriges Sauerteig ins Spiel. Da kann auch Hefe dabei sein zusätzlich, aber Sauerteig ist eine allererige dabei.
Und das ist es jetzt wirklich? Also man unterscheidet nicht mehr Brotsorten?
Kommt auf an, wenn du den Zentralverband des Deutschen Bäckerhandwerks fragst, dann ergibt es dort ein sogenanntes deutsches Brotregister. Und da sind weit über 3000 Brotspezialitäten erfasst, bewusst nicht Sorten, weil es keine klare Definition für Sorte gibt. Was ist eine Brotsorte? Für mich ist eine Brotsorte tatsächlich nur Roggenmischbrot, Roggenbrot etc., was ich gerade erzählt habe. Und unter Spezialitäten fällt dann tatsächlich alles. Also das kannst du natürlich auch auf diese handvoll Sorten zurückführen, diese 3000 Spezialitäten. Sind am Ende auch nur Roggenbrot oder Roggenmischbrot oder Weizen, irgendwas Brote, die dann halt mit speziellen Zutaten kombiniert sind, mit Kartoffeln oder mit Möhren oder mit Sonnenblumenkernen, Kürbiskernen, die speziell geformt sind oder eine spezielle Teigführung hinter sich haben, zum Beispiel drei Tage im Kühlschrank standen. So definiert sich dann eine Spezialität. Es können auch nur Orangsen sein, die da unterschiedlich sind. Und es ist schon eine neue Spezialität. Das klingt erstmal viel und das zeichnet auch quasi Deutschland aus als Brotnation, dass es so viele verschiedene Varianten gibt. Aber am Ende ist es dann doch mehr oder weniger das Gleiche, wenn man sie jetzt aufs Mehl zurückführt.
Ja, ist einfach Branding sozusagen an der Stelle.
Ja, die schmecken natürlich auch alle anders und haben alle andere Rezepturen. Aber wenn wir uns jetzt wirklich an der Verkehrsbezeichnung festmachen, dann ist es eine Handvoll von verschiedenen Brotarten.
Jetzt gibt es ja viel Varietät, also ich meine, ob man so Spezialitäten nennt oder Varianten. Du denkst dir jetzt, das klang ja am Anfang schon aus, das klang am Anfang ja schon an, du denkst dir ja immer viel Brote aus. Wenn die jetzt immer so anders sind, man aber eigentlich nur ein paar Brotsorten im Prinzip hat. Was sind denn jetzt die Stellschrauben, die primären Stellschrauben, an denen man dreht, um jetzt aus dem einen Brot ein anderes Brot werden zu lassen?
Fragst du zwei Rezeptentwickler, sagen die dir zwei verschiedene Sachen. Ich bin immer daran interessiert, bestimmte Aromen und Geschmacksrichtungen rauszukitzeln aus den Grundzutaten des Brotes. Was ich sehr selten mache, ist mit Sonderzutaten zu arbeiten. Ich packe fast nie Kürner rein in das Brot. Kürner meine ich Kürbiskern, Sondonkern, auch ganze Getreidekürner. Wegen Kürbiskern kommen sie sehr selten ins Spiel.
Das ist aber sehr beliebt, ne?
Ja, das kriege ich ständig zu hören im Blog. Fuhs doch. Das mache ich aber nicht, weil mir das immer den eigenen Brotgeschmack übertüncht. Also das hinterher, wenn mein Rezept steht, das hinterher beim zweiten Anlauf noch mal reinzugeben, ist kein Problem, aber ich möchte vorher immer erst wissen, schmeckt das Brot für sich gut? Hat seinen eigenen Charakter. Und diesen eigenen Charakter kriege ich auf verschiedenen Wegen. Das erste sind die Zutaten selbst, dass ich mir überlege, welche Mehl verwende ich, vielleicht auch welche Sorten, welche Getreidesorten und auch innerhalb einer Getreidewelt, also innerhalb des Weizens, welche Weizensorten nehme ich vielleicht dazu? Arbeite ich mit mit Hartweizen oder mit Weichweizen, nehme ich diesen speziellen Hartweizen oder einen anderen Hartweizen etc. Das wären die ersten Überlegungen, was sind, verwende ich spezielle Sorten für mein Brot. Die nächste Überlegung ist, wie ist das Mehl aufgearbeitet, also welches Mahlverfahren kommt dazu, auch das spielt eine Rolle. Auch welcher Müller macht das, aus welcher Gegend kommt das Getreide, wo ist es angebaut, nehme ich ein französisches Weizenmehl oder nehme ich ein bayerisches Weizenmehl. Die unterscheiden sich einfach über die klimatischen Verhältnisse und über die Sorten, die angebaut werden. Und wenn ich das mal ausklammere, wenn ich einfach mein Standardmehl nehme von meiner Hausmühle, dann geht es hauptsächlich darum, wie führe ich den Teig, also bei welchen Temperaturen, über welche Zeit, mit welchem Wassergehalt. Wenn Sauerteig im Spiel ist, wie führe ich auch den Sauerteig. Da gibt es auch zig verschiedene Möglichkeiten, bei verschiedenen Temperaturen, Wassergehalten, über eine Stufe, über drei Stufen, über fünf Stufen. Also füttere ich ein paar Mal nach. Bis der Sauerteig reif ist. Arbeite ich, wenn ich bei Hefe bin, mit Vorteigen. Und wenn ja, mit welchen Vorteigen. Also mische ich Mehl und Wasser und ein bisschen Hefe schon zusammen, bevor ich den Brotteig herstelle. Und lasse das separat reifen. Nehme ich einen Vorteig oder zwei oder drei. Oder packe ich Vorteig und Sauerteig kombiniert in den Brotteig. Nehme ich sogenannte Nullteige dazu, wo kein Triebmittel im Spiel ist, sondern nur Mehl und Wasser. Oder nur irgendwas anderes mit Wasser vermengt. Bringe ich zusätzlich Feuchtigkeit rein, indem ich Brühstücke mache aus Schrot oder aus gemahlenem alten Brot.
Brühstücke?
Das heißt, ich verkoche oder überbrühe irgendwas mit kochendem Wasser. Zum Beispiel so eine Art Semmelbrühe. Wenn ich Brot habe, was ich nicht mehr essen möchte, weil es altbacken geworden ist, dann wird das gewürfelt und korrostet und klein gemahlen. Das wird dann überbrüht für bestimmte Rezepte mit kochendem Wasser und bindet dadurch extrem viel Wasser. Da kriege ich die dreifache Wassermenge an das alt Brot rein. Wenn ich 100 Gramm alt Brot mit 300 Gramm Wasservermenge habe, dann habe ich am Ende, wenn es ausgekühlt ist, eine schnittfeste Masse. Das bedeutet, ich kriege mehr Feuchtigkeit ins Brot, ohne dass meine Konsistenz zu weich wird vom Teig und das sorgt am Ende wieder dafür, dass mein Brot saftiger ist, also einfach einen angenehmeren Graueindruck hinterlässt und deutlich länger frisch hält.
Und so kann man das auch noch als Brot quasi wieder zum neuen Brot machen? Genau.
Auch da gibt es rechtliche Vorgaben, wie viel altes Brot in ein Weizenbrot gehört und in ein Roggenbrot. Daran muss ich der Bäcker halten, daran muss ich auch der Hobbybäcker nicht zwingend halten. Kann man also auch anders sehen und anders tun. Jedenfalls, was ich sagen will, es gibt locker 100 verschiedene Wege und mehr noch Kombinationen, wie ich mein Rezept zusammenstelle, je nachdem, was am Ende rauskommen soll. Und wenn ich ein Rezept entwickele für irgendwen, Gastronomen oder für einen Bäcker oder für mich selbst, dann brauche ich eine möglichst exakte Beschreibung. Dessen, was da gebacken werden soll, wie soll das Brot aussehen von außen und von innen, wie soll es schmecken, wie soll es anfühlen, wie soll der Kau-Eindruck sein etc. Dann baue ich mir im Kopf dieses Bild zusammen und schließe dann bestimmte Geschichten aus, bestimmte Vorteige oder bestimmte Teigführungsarten. Und am Ende bleibt quasi nur noch ein Weg übrig, um zum Ziel zu kommen. Und dieser Weg lässt sich aber nicht wirklich im Detail beschreiben. Da ist eine große Portion Wissen dabei, das stimmt, große Portion Erfahrung und dann eine sehr, sehr große Portion Bauchgefühl.
Weil man einfach irgendwie spürt, wie viel von dem und dem mehr man jetzt wie lange vor sich hintreiben lassen soll etc. Einfach ein Erfahrungswert, den man jetzt wahrscheinlich auch ohne Weiteres nicht ausgefaltet bekommt.
Genau, es gibt schon ein paar Faustregeln, ein paar Kennwerte, an denen man sich langhangen kann. Aber am Ende spielt, wie gesagt, die Erfahrung rein, das Bauchgefühl, um möglichst wenige Fehlversuche zu haben. Als ich angefangen habe mit Rezepten zu spielen, habe ich locker 10, 20 Versuche gebraucht, bis irgendwie das Ergebnis da war, was ich haben wollte. Kann man auch alles im Blog nachlesen. Da gibt es ein Baguette-Rezept, das ich versucht habe, in Gang zu bringen. Das habe ich dann bei 25 Versuchen aufgehört und alles auch dokumentiert. Im Blog habe ich dann endgängig aufgegeben. Und mittlerweile brauche ich so ein, zwei Versuche, dass es funktioniert, dass es so aussieht, wie ich das möchte und auch so schmeckt.
Machst du dich auch an sowas wie Croissants und so weiter ran?
Ja, alles, wo irgendwie Hefe oder Sauerteig im Spiel ist. Wenn es dann Richtung Mörbeteig, Biskuit- und also Konzitoreigeschichten geht, hört dann meine Welt auf. Da habe ich dann auch kein Enthusiasmus mehr für. Sobald Leben im Spiel ist, also Mikroorganismen, bin ich da.
Dieser Reiz, seinen Brot selber zu machen. Ich kann das ja gut nachvollziehen. Wobei jetzt, wenn man dir so zuhört, kann ja schon fast abschreckend wirken, wenn man so dem Konzertmeister zuschaut, wie er seine Musik zusammen dirigiert. Das kann ja dann auch schnell zu viel werden. Aber würdest du denn sagen, dass das jetzt schon auch etwas ist, was so ein bisschen breiter Fuß fassen sollte, dass man sich sozusagen seinen Brot selber macht? Wir haben jetzt viel darüber geredet, wie kompliziert man es machen kann und wie variantenreich man es machen kann. Aber um einfach nur gutes Brot erzeugen zu wollen, braucht es ja eigentlich nicht so viel.
Nein, man kann das auch alles ganz einfach halten. Die Zutaten zusammenmischen, stehen lassen und formen und nochmal kurz stehen lassen und backen. Der wichtigste Faktor ist die Zeit. Wenn ich den Teig 24 Stunden stehen lasse, dann hat er auch seine Stoffe abgebaut, die wir im Darm nicht so gut vertragen oder nicht so gut abbauen können. Das ist alles kein Problem. Man kann es komplex gestalten, dann kommen halt andere Brote raus, als wenn man es einfach gestaltet. Aber es kommen nicht weniger gute Brote raus. Das Backen zu Hause empfehle ich selbst eigentlich immer nur, wenn man ziemlich sicher ist, dass man keinen guten Bäcker in der Ecke hat.
Das ist in den meisten Gegenden mittlerweile so?
Das ist in den meisten Gegenden so. Mir liegt relativ viel am Bäckerhandwerk. Ich bin noch mit sehr vielen Bäckern befreundet, die dann schon so backen, wie ich es mir vorstelle, zumindest ein Stück weit das Sortiment betreffend. Und die sollen natürlich am Leben bleiben, die Bäcker. Also wer einen guten Bäcker hat oder wenigstens einen Bäcker, der mit sich diskutieren lässt, sollte diesen Bäcker unterstützen und nicht selber backen. Ansonsten, hast du ja schon gesagt, gibt es in aller Regel nirgendwo mehr einen oder fast nirgendwo mehr in den großen Städten noch eher als auf dem Land Bäcker, die noch so backen, wie man es sich vielleicht auch im Idealbild vorstellt, also ohne Zusatzstoffe und von Grund auf ohne, dass sie eine Vormischung dazu mischen oder eine Fertigmischung verarbeiten. Der Trend kippt gerade wieder so ein bisschen. Also die jungen Bäcker, die jetzt anfangen, die aus der Lehre kommen, sicherlich auch nicht die Mehrheit, aber ein kleiner Teil schon, die versuchen, neue Wege zu gehen, das merke ich in den größeren Städten, das ist auch in Berlin ganz gut, aber auf dem Land, wenn ich mich bei uns umschaue, da gibt es zwar schon noch Dorfbäcker, die backen aber mindestens durchschnittlich, wenn nicht darunter. Und die, die rein ästhetisch wunderbar backen, sind dann die Großbäckereien, die backen aber inhaltlich noch schlechter als die Dorfbäcker. Die haben ein riesiges Angebot, vom Croissant bis zum fertigen klassischen Roggenmischbrot, verschiedene kleine Teilchen und alles Mögliche, also alles, was man sich so vorstellt beim Bäcker. Aber es schmeckt alles wie Pappe, also hat keinen Geschmack.
Ja, und vor allem das, was ich am schlimmsten finde bei diesen ganzen Aufbäckern, ich nenne ja nicht Bäcker, ich nenne ja Aufbäcker, weil die dann meistens sowieso nur irgendwelche vorgefertigten Teiglinge in so einen Heißluftofen reinwerfen, wobei ich immer wieder ganz beeindruckt bin, was das dann überhaupt für Ergebnisse erzielt. Also dieser Automatisierungsgrad ist schon auch bemerkenswert. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das jetzt alles nie wirklich überhaupt nicht schmecken würde. Zumindest so bei Brötchen und Croissants und so weiter, werden ja relativ gute Ergebnisse erzielt. Zumal das ja auch Waren sind, die man in der Regel auch schnell wieder verspeist, aber bei Brot finde ich ist immer der Unterschied immer enorm. Gerade wenn man so ein Brot kauft, die werden so unheimlich schnell trocken. Halten sie sich also irgendwie gar nicht. Ich muss sagen, ich bin hier relativ gesegnet, weil trotz meiner urbanen Platzierung habe ich hier innerhalb von einem Umkreis von zwei Kilometern gibt es so zwei Traditionsbäcker, die es hier schon sozusagen aus dem Osten noch geschafft haben, auch zu überleben. Der eine vor allem durch so eine Spezialisierung eben auf diese wir haben keine Zusatzstoffe, was lustigerweise nicht nur jetzt so eine biogesund, fanatische Neubürgerschaft anzieht oder die Allergiker, die auch, sondern die andere Zielgruppe sind interessanterweise die jüdische Gesellschaft, die hier dann doch noch vertreten ist, die es sozusagen einfach aus Koscha-Aspekten auch macht. Bei dem anderen Bäcker weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, was ihn trägt, aber auch da ist es irgendwie so die Tradition bis hin, dass sich viele Leute jetzt dafür eingesetzt haben, dass die Miete nicht erhöht wird und so weiter, weil es ja nun nicht ganz einfach ist, mit dem Bäckerhandwerk da zu überleben. Wenn es jetzt so einen Trend gibt, würde ich das natürlich sehr begrüßen. Ich denke, das ist irgendwie auch Zeit, weil das ist einfach ein Elend irgendwie in diesen ganzen durchformatierten Aufbackproduktionen. Aber was macht denn deren Brot eigentlich so schlecht?
Das sind wieder verschiedene Sachen.
Vor allem, warum trocknet das so schnell weg?
Ja, du hast ja schon den Unterschied gemacht zwischen Kleingebäck und Brot. Kleingebäcke, da muss man nicht so zwingend als Bäcker und auch nicht als industrieller Bäcker darauf achten, dass die Frischhaltung passt, weil die fast noch warm verschweißt werden. Bei Broten sieht das ein bisschen anders aus. Die müssen eigentlich, also ein Roggenmischbrot zum Beispiel, locker eine Woche durchhalten, dass es noch genießbar ist. Es wird immer ein bisschen fester und in der Krümel vielleicht nicht, aber fester wird es auf jeden Fall. Aber nach einer Woche sollte es schon noch genießbar sein. Wenn dem nicht so ist, dann fehlt dem Rezept schrägst du dich dem Brot Zeit. Das ist wieder der Faktor. Wenn du in einer Fabrik Brot backst, dann bist du darauf angewiesen, dass du erstens einen durchlaufenden Prozess hast, kontinuierlich, und du brauchst Lagerkapazität. Wenn du Brote mit Zeit backen willst, brauchst du extreme Lagerkapazitäten. Dann hast du keinen Ritt in einem Strang durch. Die meisten Großbäckereien, ich kenne sie jetzt von Harry Brot, arbeiten schon mit eigenen Sauerteigen für die Brote. Das sind dann einerseits Reizuchtsauerteige, also die Geschichte mit Monotonie im Geschmack im Vergleich zu einem Spontan-Sauerteig, der deutlich komplexere Aromen entwickeln kann. Die andere Geschichte ist, dass meistens Hefe noch dazukommt als Triebmittel, weil man dem Sauerteig selbst nicht traut in seiner Leistung, die er hat. Und dann entsprechend die Zeit. Die Zeit wird reduziert, die Hefemenge wird relativ hochgeschraubt. Und dann hast du solche 0-15 Brote. Zum letzten Kurs bei mir im Ort hat eine Teilnehmerin von unserem Großbäcker ein Roggenbrot mitgebracht. Ohne, dass ich wusste, dass es vom Großbäcker ist. Es hätte auch selbst gebacken sein können. War ein Kastenbrot. Hat sie mir zum Verkosten hingelegt. Normalerweise riecht man da erst mal rein, drückt das Brot zusammen und riecht in die Krume. Und kostet dann. Da hat weder irgendwas gerochen, noch hat es noch irgendwas geschmeckt. Das war angeblich ein reines Roggenbrot. Kenn ich so nicht. Wenn ich mein eigenes reines Roggenbrot backe, dann sind da so viele Aromen. Da könnte ich mich reinlegen in das Brot, auch nach einer Woche noch. Und das war komplett neutral. Und da so richtig durchschaut, habe ich noch nicht, warum die Brote immer so schmecken müssen bei Großbäckern. Aber es ist in aller Regel so. Also es liegt einerseits sicherlich an der Zeit und andererseits am Sauerteig. Und dass man bestimmte Sachen, die zu aufwendig wären für so ein Brot, so ein bisschen Vorarbeiten, einfach weglässt.
Aber was trägt denn jetzt konkret dazu bei, dass die Dinger so schnell austrocknen? Ist das bei Design? Dass die Leute möglichst schnell wieder ein neues Brot kaufen sollen? Ich hoffe nicht. Aber was fehlt dem Brot, dass es diese Frische nicht halten kann? Ich finde das ja total erstaunlich. Man ist es ja fast nicht mehr gewohnt. Ich mag das vollkommen normal sein. Aber dass da ein Brot eine Woche liegt, ohne dass man das jetzt nochmal gesondert mit Plastikfolie oder so einrahmt, was wahrscheinlich eh keine gute Idee wäre. Warum kann das gut gebackene Brot so lange diese Feuchtigkeit verhalten? Und das Industriebrot tut es nicht?
Das eine ist die Feuchtigkeit selbst. Wenn du viel Wasser in den Teig gibst, hält das Brot länger frisch. Viel Wasser heißt aber auch weichere Teige. Und nicht alle Anlagen sind fähig, weiche Teige zu händeln. Es gibt mittlerweile schon Anlagen, die das schaffen. Und es gibt auch Bäckereien, die solche Anlagen haben, die relativ weichen Teigen umgehen können. Aber eben nicht alle, das ist der eine Punkt. Und wenn du von Hand aufarbeitest, also von Hand den Teig formst, dann kannst du mit fast jeder Teigkonsistenz leben.
Aber mit Maschinen natürlich.
Das kommt dann auf die Fertigkeit des Bäckers an. Der Hand an, aber nicht alle Maschinen. Also jede Maschine hat ihr Optimum an Teigkonsistenz. Und daraufhin wird halt der Teig geschaffen sein.
Das heißt, es ist gar nicht mal so sehr, dass es nicht die Feuchtigkeit halten kann, sondern es hat einfach von vornherein gar nicht diese Feuchtigkeit.
Das ist der eine Punkt, der sein kann, aber nicht immer muss. Und der andere Punkt ist dann tatsächlich der Zeitfaktor, wie lange reift mein Teig, wie ist der saure Teig beschaffen, gebe ich noch Hefe dazu oder nicht? Wenn ich Hefe zugebe, vor allem in größeren Mengen, ist es einfach ein Erfahrungswert. Ganz erklären kann ich mir das noch nicht. Wird das Brot schneller altbacken, als wenn ich beispielsweise ein reines Saure-Teigbrot backe? Und letzten Endes ist es tatsächlich auch die Reifezeit. Wie viel Zeit hat der Teig, um bestimmte Stoffe abzubauen? Arbeite ich mit Vor-Teigen, die auch noch mal zu einer längeren Frischhaltung beitragen? Arbeite ich mit Saure-Teig über verschiedenen Stufen oder nur über eine Stufe? Die Grundregel ist, je mehr Zeit ich in den Teig gehe und je mehr Aufwand ich vor dem eigentlichen Brotteig mit dem Brot backen habe, umso länger hält mir das Brot furcht.
Wie lagert man denn das Brot optimal?
Auf keinen Fall im Kühlschrank. Da kommen ganz viele Menschen drauf, das im Kühlschrank zu lagern, weil man ja sonst alles, was halten soll, in den Kühlschrank packt. Kühlschrank ist eine ganz schlechte Idee, weil das Brot dann deutlich schneller alt backen wird. Wenn man es im Kühlschrank lagert, dann lagert man es meistens auch in einer Plastiktüte oder in einer Plastikbox. Auch das ist grundverkehrt, weil das Brot atmen können muss. Es darf nicht irgendwie eingeschlossen sein und anfangen feucht zu werden. Mein Optimum ist ein Steingut-Ton-Topf mit Holzdeckel. Der Holzdeckel reguliert die Feuchtigkeit. Es geht auch mit Ton-Topf mit Ton-Deckel, dann sollten aber irgendwo Löcher drin sein und er sollte nicht komplett glasiert sein, um auch wieder diesen Feuchtigkeitsaustausch zu gewährleisten. Was auch ganz gut geht, sind Holzkisten, Holztöpfe, die dann aber relativ dickwandig sein sollten. Ich habe mal einen Versuch gemacht, das war glaube ich damals für die ARD, da gab es mal eine Sendung über Brotfrischhaltung. Da haben wir so einen stinknormalen Brotkasten aus Holz hingestellt, der relativ dünnwandig ist, aus Latten zusammengeschustert. Und da hat das Brot reingestellt. Das war am Ende nach drei Tagen glaube ich genauso trocken, wie das, was wir im Leinsack hatten oder das, was einfach noch draußen stand. Also diese Truhe hat überhaupt gar nichts gebracht. Das hat dickwandig, damit da auch wenig Feuchtigkeit rausgeht, aber ein bisschen regulierend.
Also es muss sozusagen die Feuchtigkeit schon vorhalten, aber es muss trotzdem noch einen Luftaustausch möglich sein.
Genau, das beugt dem Schimmel vor. Du hast ja immer Temperaturschwankungen in dem Zimmer, wo du es lagerst, in der Küche. Und wenn es warm ist, dann gibt das Brot Feuchtigkeit ab. Wenn es kalt ist, kondensiert im schlimmsten Fall Feuchtigkeit irgendwo. Am Topf oder am Brot, und das muss irgendwie reguliert werden. Das schafft der Tontopf am besten oder der Holztopf.
Weil das Steingut einfach die Temperatur quasi konstant hält?
Ja, andererseits kann es zumindest Wasser aufnehmen und Wasser wieder abgeben, je nachdem, wie die Temperaturverhältnisse sind.
Das Steingut nimmt Wasser auf?
Wenn es nicht glasiert ist. Noch recht oberdach gesagt. Das ist der Pohois und die Feuchtigkeit kann sich da niederschlagen.
Jetzt will ich aber doch noch mal zum Schluss so ein bisschen auf das Zuhause machen kommen. Klar, einerseits so selber machen mit dem gebotenen Aufwand. Ich denke, da gab es schon die eine oder andere Inspiration. Aber auch als Alternative zu schlechten Bäckern, mit denen man vielleicht irgendwo umzingelt ist, weil nicht jeder die Situation wie ich hier hat, dass ich mit ein paar Meter mehr Investitionen dann schon ein extrem passables Brot bekommen kann. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass wenn man sich jetzt zum Brotnerd entwickelt und zu Hause Brot macht, dass man dann auf einmal nie mehr in Bäckereien geht, wo man vielleicht sogar noch eher den Weg dorthin findet. So ein bisschen mit Home-Taping ist killing music. Das hat ja auch nicht funktioniert. Und ich glaube auch Home-Baking killt den Bäcker nicht.
Im Gegenteil.
Jetzt gibt es ja diesen Trend der Brotbackmaschinen, die einfach diesen schönen Convenience-Faktor haben, dass man so über Nacht dann einfach so ein frisches Brot hat morgens. Was hälst du von sowas?
Diesen Trend gibt es immer mal, den gab es schon vor 20 Jahren. Mein Großvater hat damals auch so ein Gerät gehabt, hat es glaube ich immer noch. Und mittlerweile gibt es sozusagen Brotkapselautomaten. Also das, was man mit Kaffee kennt, gibt es mittlerweile auch in Brotform. Du kaufst erst eine Kapsel mit den Zutaten und packst das in den Automat und der macht alles für dich. Gibt es auch. Aber genauso Quatsch, wie ich finde, wie die ganz normalen Brotbackautomaten. Weil du in aller Regel immer darauf angewiesen bist, eine Fertigmischung da reinzupacken. Wenn du sichere Ergebnisse haben willst, ohne viel nachdenken zu müssen. Und wenn du auf die Fertigmischung schaust, auf die Zutaten, dann sind da meistens genau die Sachen drin, die du eigentlich vermeiden willst, die du beim Großbäcker unter Umständen einkaufst, als Brot oder auch beim normalen Bäcker.
Was sind das für Sachen?
Im einfachsten Fall Ascorbinsäure, also ein synthetisches Vitamin C. Etwas komplexer sind dann Immugatoren, verschiedenste Art oder neuerdings technische Enzyme, die sozusagen das Wundermittel sind, um nichts mehr deklarieren zu müssen auf dem fertigen Brot. Man hat einen Clean Label Brote auf dem Mehl, also auf der Tüte muss es noch draufstehen. Wenn es dann gebacken ist, muss es nicht mehr draufstehen.
Weil die Enzyme sozusagen Dinge erzeugen, die vorher gar nicht mit reingegeben wurden, aber de facto am Ende mit dabei sind.
Die Enzyme sind Eiweißstoffe, die verschwinden nach Definition durch die Hitze, also gerinnen, wie ein normales Ei auch, beim Kochen. Da gibt es aber Streitpunkte in der Frage, ist aber ein komplett anderes Thema. Ich sehe sie eher kritisch, sind aber momentan die Wunderwaffe nicht nur um Brot, sondern in allen Lebensmitteln, auch in verschiedenen anderen Lebensbereichen. Waschmittel zum Beispiel. Es wird überall mit Enzymen gearbeitet, die in aller Regel natürlich nicht vorkommen, sondern im Labor hergestellt werden. Auch mit gentechnischen Verfahren hergestellt werden. Auch da kann man ganz viele kritische Sachen noch erzählen. Aber in der Vormischung stecken meistens Sachen drin, die man vermeiden möchte, wenn man selbst backt. Und am Ende hat man letztendlich kein besseres Brot als das, was man sowieso durchschnittlich kaufen kann, außer dass man es halt frischer hat als da, wo man spart sich den Weg. Und kann das unter Umständen lauwarm essen und ist der Meinung, das ist dann frischer und schmeckt besser. Aber im Normalfall ist es nichts anderes als das, was böse gesagt der Durchschnittsbäcker auch backt oder man in verschiedensten Aufbackstationen in Supermärkten Angebote bekommt.
Okay, wenn ich jetzt die Brotmaschinen, die Klugen oder die Kapselautomaten und die Brotbackmischung weglasse und quasi auf die hier schon beschriebene klassische Methode jetzt arbeite, reicht denn ein normaler Backofen?
Ja, definitiv. Ich backe alles im normalen Haushaltsofen. Auch alles, was irgendwo publiziert ist in Büchern und im Netz ist alles im Haushaltsofen gebacken.
Also man braucht jetzt nicht so einen riesigen Steinofen, wo man so zentralisch seine Brote reinschiebt?
Das ist dann bloß eine Menge Frage. Wenn ich vorhabe, 10, 20 Brote auf einmal zu backen, dann ist schon die Überlegung sinnvoll, ob man sich einen Holzofen kauft oder einen Elektro-Steinbackofen oder einfach einen Profi-Bäckerofen, in dem Dimension geht alles. Wenn ich nur vorhabe, ein, zwei Brote zu backen, auf einen Schlag, dann locker am Haushaltsofen.
Was ist denn jetzt sozusagen die beste Strategie für Leute, die ordentliches Brot haben wollen, aber die schlicht keine Infrastruktur haben, die erträglich wäre? Was würde es so vorschlagen, wie man da rangeht? Einfach, um jede Woche quasi korrektes Brot zu haben, was sich ein paar Tage hält?
Auf jeden Fall nicht verzetteln. Also ein, zwei Rezepte raussuchen, am besten erst mal eins. Sich da rein fitzen. Wenn man so ein Rezept liest, wird man erst mal auf ein paar Fachbegriffe stoßen, die man vielleicht nicht kennt. Und versuchen, diese Fachbegriffe zu klären, zu verstehen, wie ist der Ablauf. Also das muss man tatsächlich einmal im Kopf haben. Der grundsätzliche Ablauf, wie es zum Brot kommt. Und dieses Rezept dann stur durchexerzieren, das wird beim ersten Mal schiefgehen, beim zweiten Mal vielleicht nicht ganz so schiefgehen, aber trotzdem noch schiefgehen. Und so steigert man sich dann irgendwann zum optimalen Ergebnis. Und wenn man dieses eine Rezept drauf hat, dann kann man, wenn man noch mag, zum nächsten Rezept wandern. Man sollte erstmal ein Rezept perfektionieren für sich, um auch mal ein Erfolgserlebnis zu haben und mit den Grundprinzipien warm zu werden. Und dann geht's weiter. Was für zu Hause wichtig ist, habe ich vorhin schon mal angesprochen, dass man ein Gefühl dafür entwickelt, wann geht der Teig in den Ofen und wann wird er vorher verarbeitet. Wann er in den Ofen geht, ist kritischer, ist wichtiger, als wann wird er weiterverarbeitet. Und der Ofen selbst, wie gesagt, reicht als normaler Haushaltsofen. Wenn es geht, mit einem heißen Untergrund backen, also im einfachsten Fall ein heißes Blech, damit der Brotteig gebremst wird, wenn er in den Ofen geht und nicht in die Breite läuft. Und durch die Hitze gebremst wird.
Und wenn man da so ein Stein...
Stein wäre die bessere Methode, ein Backstein.
Macht die auch bei Pizza.
Genau. Aber wenn man erstmal keine Investition haben will, dann einfach ein Blech mit vorheizen und darauf den Teig setzen. Dampfen kann man auch, wenn man mag. Am Anfang Dampfen, den Ofen bedampfen. Der Dampf hat ganz viele positive Einwirkungen auf das Brot.
Auch auf Ofen, die man bedampfen kann?
Also ja, gibt's schon. Die, die man kaufen kann, die sich noch Haushaltsofen nennen, die haben eine Dampffunktion, die ist zum Brotbacken eher weniger geeignet, kostet zwar viel Geld, aber ist weniger zum Brotbacken geeignet, eher zum Gemüse garen und dämpfen. Aber nicht zum Brotbacken. Wenn man dampfen will, dann eher manuell. Also zum Beispiel ein Blech mit aufheizen und darauf eine Tasse Wasser kippen. Oder noch besser wäre eine Schale mit viel Metall oder Steinchen aufzuheizen und darauf dann das entsprechende Wasser zu kippen. Dann gibt es einen stärkeren Dampfstoß und man braucht sehr viel Dampf in wenig Zeit beim Brotbacken. Ziemlich am Anfang. Und die Öfen, von denen ich gerade sprach, mit Dampffunktion, die dampfen auf Knopfdruck relativ lange, aber wenig. Genau, der umgekehrte Effekt. Aber um es ganz einfach zu machen, am Anfang einfach ohne Dampf backen, es kommt trotzdem Brot raus, es wird nicht glänzen und vielleicht ein bisschen rustikal, wild aufgerissen sein, aber es geht. Oder man backt im Topf, das geht auch. Im Gusseisentopf mit Deckel spart man sich die Dampferei und spart sich auch den Backstein. Eine sehr schöne Technik.
Kann man bestimmt alles bei dir im Blog rauskramen, oder?
Kann man im Blog nachlesen, in den verschiedenen Büchern, kann man es auch nachlesen. Und auch in tausend anderen Internetseiten.
Was wünschst du dir denn so für die Brot-Szene? Oder was tut sich denn da so? Du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, es gibt so einen Trend von neuen Bäckereien, so ein Back-to-the-Roots-Moment. Ist das ein zartes Plänzchen?
Das ist ein sehr zartes Plänzchen. Also wie kann man vielleicht an vier, fünf Händen abzählen?
Hat denn das überhaupt Zukunft? Wir sind ja wieder beim Bier. Auch da gab es ja einen ähnlichen Trend. Wir hatten diese Großbrauereien, die alles aufkaufen, das auch immer noch tun, überhaupt so eine Verflachung, so ein allgemeines Durchschnittspilz, was eben 90 Prozent abdeckt, bis hin dann eben auch so ein Brauereisterben eingesetzt hat. Sicherlich gibt es noch so Regionen wie Franken, die die Fahne noch ziemlich weit oben halten und sich eine Diversität erhalten haben und vielleicht auch resistent sind. Aber trotzdem gibt es jetzt auch so diese kleinen Brauereien, die jetzt überall rauskommen, die im Prinzip das sehr gut machen. Und vorhin, was hast du noch mal gesagt, zu den USA, wo dort schon, ging es da schon um Brot, also was in den USA besonders überraschend gut war, ganz am Anfang?
Es gibt ein paar gute Bäcker, aber das ist halt auch eine Minderheit im Vergleich zu denen.
Ja genau, aber es gibt auch gerade in den USA auch im Brauereiwesen einen riesigen Push. Also bei den internationalen Wettbewerben und so weiter sind die Amerikaner mal ganz weit vorne, weil die einfach so eine Reaktion auf schlechte Bedingungen auch gezeigt haben. Also sich sozusagen so ein Wunsch nach guter Qualität entwickelt hat, der mittlerweile eben so eine relativ blühende Landschaft von kleinen Brauereien ermöglicht hat. Und ich meine jetzt gerade auch mit den Distributionsmöglichkeiten des Netzes etc. hat man ja dann auch ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Während eine Brauerei früher eigentlich immer nur regional aktiv werden kann, gibt es ja heute schon andere Möglichkeiten. Ich könnte mir jetzt gut beim Brot, wird es immer sehr regional bleiben, aber in dem Moment, wo Brot halt auch wirklich gut ist. Also ich finde allein schon Brot, was ein paar Tage frisch bleibt, ist einfach im Wert gegenüber, ich schmeiße immer die Hälfte weg und kaufe mir danach jeden Tag immer wieder etwas, was eigentlich genauso bekloppt schmeckt. So ist ja auch kein Wert. Und ich denke, da könnte sich durchaus so ein Wertewandel auch vollziehen, der vielleicht eben solchen Bäckereien auch wieder die Möglichkeit gibt, da zu überleben.
Das Problem ist, dass die Bäckereien, die dann tatsächlich gutes Brot backen, und von denen gibt es dann denke ich schon ein paar mehr als heute, in ein paar Jahren, dass die trotzdem eine extreme Minderheit sind. Die große Masse an Brotkonsum wird über den Einzelhandel abgedickt. Und dann gibt es einzelne Bäckereien, Gourmet-Bäckereien nenne ich die immer, die sozusagen die klassische Schiene bedienen, also richtig gute Brote backen mit traditionellen Verfahren in modernem Gewand arbeiten und dann entsprechend Brot relativ hochpreisig verkaufen müssen und auch können an die Leute, die sie es leisten können und möchten. Und alles andere wird über das Durchschnittsbrot, über den Einzelhandel abgedeckt. Also die klassische Bäckerei wird es nicht mehr geben. Die werden aussterben, die sterben sowieso aus. Ich glaube seit 1998 ist die Hälfte der Bäckereien weggestorben, wie es damals noch gab im Vergleich zu heute.
Unpopuläre Arbeitszeiten, das kommt noch dazu.
Ja, wobei selbst das kann man heutzutage über Kühltechnik und selbst ohne Kühltechnik kann man das so steuern, über die Rezeptur, dass man tagsüber backen kann. Es gibt auch ein paar Beispiele, warum muss man früh um 5 Uhr oder um 7 Uhr sein Brot kaufen, kann man auch nachmittags machen.
Wenn es lange noch hält, ja. Ja, aber die Brötchen.
Oder man deckt am Vortag tatsächlich. Man kann die Rezeptur so gestalten, dass das Brot tagsüber gebacken wird, nachmittags gebacken wird und früh verkauft wird.
Weißt du, diese Nachtarbeit ist mehr Tradition als Notwendigkeit?
Ja, also ein vernünftiger Bäcker muss nachts nicht mehr arbeiten. Bin ich voll überzeugt. Wobei ich kann verstehen, dass sie nachts arbeiten. Das ist ein anderes Arbeitsklima. Ich bin ja auch relativ viel in Bäckereien unterwegs, auch nachts. Und es ist schon ein anderes Arbeiten nachts, als wenn du tagsüber da irgendwo stehst. Du bist völlig abgeschottet, draußen ist dunkel. Du kannst dein Ding machen, bist konzentrierter. Aber es ist egal, was mir noch zum Thema USA eingefallen ist. Auch zu hier, also die Bäcker, die ich kenne, die hier richtig gut sind, sind fast alles Quereinsteiger. Die also ursprünglich mal was anderes gelernt haben und andere Dinge getan haben im beruflichen Leben.
So wie Geologie.
Also wie Geologie. Und die USA und auch andere Länder haben den großen Vorteil, wie ich finde, dass Quereinsteigern wenig in den Weg gelegt wird, um das zu tun, was sie machen wollen. In Deutschland gibt es den Meisterzwang, vor allem bei Bäckereiwesen. Das heißt, selbst wenn jetzt jemandem einfällt und er kann es auch, gutes Brot zu backen, kann er es nicht einfach so tun. Also er kann es schon tun, aber darf es nicht verkaufen. Darf es nicht in den Verkehr bringen. Dazu braucht er den Meistertitel oder zumindest eine Ausnahmegenehmigung, an die auch nicht so leicht zu kommen ist. Dann darf er auch nicht das gesamte Spektrum backen, sondern nur spezielle Dinge, die genehmigt wurden. Also ich glaube, eine große Hürde, um ein wenig mehr Vielfalt und gutes Brot in Deutschland zu haben, ist tatsächlich der Meisterzwang. Das, was eigentlich mal dazu gedacht war, die Qualität zu schützen und auf einem guten Niveau zu halten, hemmt jetzt aus meiner Sicht die Innovation und den Drang nach neuen Arten zu backen. Und ich merke es ja selber an mir, ich backe relativ viel Brot und das Einzige, was ich tun kann, ist es zu verschenken.
Weil ich den Status hast. Stattdessen verkaufen aber Bäckereien, also Outlets sozusagen, eigentlich die Backwaren an die Massen, von Backen, die keinen Tod und Blas haben.
Das Kuriose ist ja, ich könnte jetzt hingehen, mir einen Laden mieten, mir von verschiedensten Firmen, die Tiefkühlbackwaren herstellen, sogar deutsche Firmen, man muss sie nicht irgendwo aus Polen herziehen, die deutschen Firmen, ich könnte mir die Tiefkühlbackwaren holen, die in den Ofen werfen und dann verkaufen, das darf ich. Man darf sogar Bäckerei oben drüber schreiben, ist nicht geschützt. Der Begriff, das darf ich, was ich nicht darf, ist, mich in den gleichen Laden zu stellen und einen Teig zu machen und den dann zu backen und zu verkaufen.
Weil, du bist ja Kindmeister und kannst das ja nicht.
Und?
Wird sich das ändern können? Oder ist das Bickereihandwerk dabei, sich selber zu Tode zu schützen?
Den Eindruck hab ich manchmal, man ist sehr stolz auf das Bäckerei-Handwerk, in den Innungen und in den verschiedenen Gremien und da tut sich auch was, dann hat sich auch relativ viel getan in der Herangehensweise. Man ist sehr viel offener geworden, auch für Quereinsteiger, das stimmt schon. Aber es ist äußerst schwierig, als Quereinsteiger eine Bäckerei aufzumachen. Entweder kaufst du dir einen Bäckermeister, also stellst einen ein, der dann da steht und von dem du ja dann letztlich abhängig bist, der dann auch deine Philosophie irgendwie mittragen muss. Oder du musst halt die Ausbildung durchlaufen und das wäre für mich eine Zeit von zwei, zweieinhalb Jahren bis zum Meister, die ich erstmal irgendwie finanziell überbrücken müsste.
Wo du wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so viel lernen würdest jetzt neu?
Das kommt dazu, also handwerklich sicherlich, aber theoretisch würde ich behaupten fast nichts. Aber ich würde das schon machen, wenn es jetzt nicht zweieinhalb Jahre dauern würde, wenn ich es finanziell überstehen könnte, dann bricht ja relativ viel weg, womit ich momentan meine Brötchen verdiene. Genau, also es gibt tausend Wege, um Brot verkaufen zu dürfen, aber jeder Weg ist äußerst komplex und schwierig für Querentsteiger. Und das ist in den USA anders. Wenn ich der Meinung bin, ich kann gutes Brot backen, dann mach ich meinen Laden auf. Muss sicherlich auch die Hygienevorschriften einhalten, das muss jeder. Aber der Zwang zum Meister will mir vor allem im Bäckereiwesen nicht in den Kopf, weshalb das sein muss.
Vor allem gibt es ja auch immer weniger Stellen, wo man diese Meisterschaft überhaupt erlernen kann.
Die gibt es schon noch. Die Bäckereien selbst, da hast du recht, die fallen weg. Die Fachschulen gibt es noch. Das theoretische Wissen, teilweise das praktische Wissen, kannst du schon noch erlernen. Aber die Bäckereien, vor allem die kleinen Bäckereien, wo man eigentlich das lernen könnte, was man als guter Bäcker lernen möchte, die werden immer weniger. Und letzten Endes, die Begründung für den Meisterzwang ist neben anderen aber auch immer der Hygieneaspekt. Und das ist aber ein Argument, das ich nicht gelten lasse, weil das jeder einhalten muss. Auch wenn ich ein Restaurant aufmache, bei den Küchen gibt es keinen Meisterzwang mehr, das kann jeder machen. Und da ist es noch viel kritischer, was Hygiene angeht, als wenn ich mit Mehlhand jahre.
Ja, vor allem zum Eierbrot, was mal im Ofen war, einfach nicht so kritisch ist wie frisch verarbeitete Fleischstückchen und Eierspeisen und ähnliche Sachen. Wird das nochmal fallen?
Die EU sägt wohl dran am Meisterzwang generell, aber ich denke, die deutschen Bäcker sind relativ wehrhaft.
Die wollen dann, was das angeht, mit Pauken und Trompeten ihren Niedergang entgegenmeistern.
Also ein ganz, ganz negatives Bild über die deutschen Bäcker möchte ich auch nicht ziehen. Der Durchschnittsbäcker ist schon so gestrickt, dass am Ende aus meiner Sicht zumindest kein gutes Brot rauskommt, aber es gibt schon wirklich gute Bäcker. Und die lassen sich auch, wie gesagt, an wenigen Händen abziehen.
Ja, mal gucken, wie viele Quereinsteiger jetzt noch dazukommen. Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das so... Also ich spüre generell, wie beim Bier auch schon, auch bei anderen Sachen, so eine Bereitschaft, so das selber machen, auch wieder zu entdecken, weil das ja auch so generell eine Fähigkeit ist, die verloren gegangen ist. Ganz unabhängig jetzt vom Backen. Die Frage wird nicht nur ich mir gestellt haben, aber so dieses, was ist, wenn jetzt morgen die Zivilisation weg ist? Was passiert, wenn ich so im Wald fallen gelassen werde? Habe ich überhaupt das Grundverständnis, mir auch nur meine nötigsten, mindestens grundlegendsten Nahrungsbedürfnisse zu sichern? Verstehe ich überhaupt genug darüber? Es gibt so einen schönen YouTube-Kanal, wo so ein Typ, ein USA, ich weiß gar nicht, wo der da wohnt, aber irgendwo in so einem schönen Waldgebiet, wo es irgendwie alles gibt, ja, wie heißt der nochmal? Paleo Technology oder irgendwie sowas. Und er dokumentiert sich dann immer sehr aufwendig auf Video, wie er einfach Dinge from scratch macht. Also er baut Häuser, Öfen, Heizungen, Dachziegel, also baut sich seine eigenen Lehmöfen, in dem er Dachziegel brennt, daraus ein Haus macht und so weiter. All die Werkzeuge, die er dafür verwendet hat, natürlich vorher auch selbst gemacht. Also wirklich nur mit Lehm, Holz, Stein. Und ich finde den Ansatz bemerkenswert. Und könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass nochmal sowas Ähnliches auch quasi so im Nahrungsmittel kommt. Und Brot ist halt irgendwie so nah quasi an der Natur, abgesehen natürlich jetzt von den Kulturpflanzen, die natürlich über lange, lange Zeit entstanden sind. Aber gut, man muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt in der Jungsteinzeit anfangen. Letztlich leben wir ja in diesem Hier und Jetzt.
Aber das ist ein gutes Stichwort. Man kann tatsächlich sehr rudimentär Brot backen. Also man braucht einen Ofen sicherlich, egal was, oder eine Hitzequelle, sagen wir es so. Aber ansonsten im schlimmsten Fall auch ohne Waage.
Wobei Salz lässt sich jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres im Wald finden.
Ja, aber auch da kannst du mit Kräutern z.B. gegensteuern. Es gibt relativ salzartige Kräuter oder sehr würzige Sachen kannst du reingeben. Selbst das kannst du irgendwie beeinflussen. Für mein Warenkundebuch, das ich geschrieben habe, da gibt es ein salzfreies Brot, tatsächlich ein salzreduziertes Brot. Und das arbeitet tatsächlich mit Kräutern. Man braucht einen Ofen und eine Art Schüssel und Wasser und das Getreide und gut ist.
Lutz, vielen Dank. Das war eine super Reise hier durch die Welt des Brots. Bitte schön, hat mich gefreut. Das war mal wieder ein CRE. Viele weitere Planungen, nur mit den Terminen. Immer nicht ganz so einfach, aber ihr hart ja immer aus und hofft aufs Beste und ich bin mit mich auch wieder neue Themen aufzugraben. Bis dahin sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.